I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Oh my goodness, Jenna Fisher.
Angela Kinsey.
我是詹娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探讨办公室的世界。我们是Office Ladies 6.0版。哦天哪，詹娜·菲舍尔。安吉拉·金斯利。
We have a big episode today.
Office Ladies, you guys, has hit a huge,
milestone this month. And we're going to do a whole episode to celebrate it. We want to celebrate it
with you guys. Jenna, tell them what's happening. We just hit over 500 million downloads for Office
Ladies' podcast. Yeah, 500 million. Yeah. Over. Over. We'd been tracking it, Lady, and all of a
sudden, when we went back to see where we were, we were actually at 501 million.
We missed it by a whole million.
I know.
我们今天有一期重磅节目。Office Ladies，天哪，这个月迎来了巨大的里程碑。我们要专门做一整期节目来庆祝它。我们想和大家一起庆祝。詹娜，告诉他们发生了什么。我们的《Office Ladies》播客下载量刚刚突破5亿次。是的，5亿次。是的。超过了。超过了。我们一直在追踪，女士，突然之间，当我们回去查看我们处于什么位置时，我们实际上已经达到了5.01亿。我们整整错过了100万。我知道。
You brought in balloons that spell out 500 million.
You told me you were going to do this.
I said, lady, I don't, is it necessary?
You said, quote, I feel very strongly about this.
You said it in a tone.
I did.
Like that you were like, I am not fucking around.
This is a big number.
你带了拼出5.00亿的氢气球。你告诉过我要这么做。我说，女士，我不知道，这有必要吗？你说，原话是，“我对这件事感觉非常强烈。”你用了一种语气。我确实用了。就像你当时说的一样，我可不是在开玩笑。这是一个很大的数字。
Yeah.
Balloons, it is.
Well, balloons, damn it.
And here's the thing I didn't realize when I ordered them is that we had to blow them up.
Yeah.
It feels like when you've hit 500 million downloads, someone else blows up your balloons.
是的。是的。气球，就是这样。好吧，气球，该死的。我订购时没有意识到的一点是，我们必须自己给它们充气。是的。是的。感觉就像当你的下载量达到5亿次时，应该由别人来帮你吹气球。
No, as it turns out, no, you do it.
You do it over a week at home with your husband.
Thank you, Josh.
You also brought in a treat.
I did.
We have a cake because you guys on office ladies, we celebrate everything with cake.
We have a cake.
Guess what, guys.
不，事实证明，没有，得你自己来。你在家里花了一个星期和你的丈夫一起做。谢谢你，乔治。你还带来了一份点心。是的。我们有一个蛋糕，因为你们这些Office Ladies的听众，我们用蛋糕庆祝一切。我们有一个蛋糕。你猜怎么着，伙计们。
It didn't have space for the word million.
It says 500.
Great.
500 what?
They don't know when they made it.
They didn't know.
I don't know.
I think basically it's like Jim and Dwight planned our 500 million download party because we have some sad balloons.
它没有地方写“百万”这个词。上面写着500。太棒了。500什么？他们做的时候也不知道。他们不知道。我不知道。我想基本上就像吉姆和德怀特策划了我们的5亿下载派对，因为我们有一些悲伤的气球。
We have a sad cake.
But we have lots of happiness in our heart, you guys.
Yes.
And I got you something.
You got me something?
I did.
And me.
I got a smashing gifts.
我们有一个悲伤的蛋糕。但是我们的心中充满了快乐，伙计们。是的。我给你带了件东西。你给我带了件东西？是的。还有我。我得到了很棒的礼物。
What is it?
This is very own brand for me.
Because over the years, I've gotten as many matching gifts.
This is true.
You're probably never going to wear this.
It's something I wear.
Yeah.
I got so dialed in to this number, 500 million.
是什么？这是为我量身定制的品牌。因为多年来，我收到了很多情侣礼物。这是真的。你可能永远都不会戴这个。这是我戴的东西。是的。我对这个数字500万非常执着。
Are you crazy?
It's nuts.
What is it?
Is it?
It's a gold necklace.
Oh, I was afraid it was a shirt that said 500 million.
No.
I thought about a hoodie.
你疯了吗？这太疯狂了。是什么？是吗？是一条金项链。哦，我生怕它是一件写着500万的衬衫。没有。我想过连帽衫。
I didn't do it.
I got us each a necklace.
Look, it's gold-plated, and then the nethered.
number 500 is going to hang around your neck.
Let me see this.
I love it.
And you know what?
我没买那个。我给我们俩每人买了一条项链。看，它是镀金的，然后数字500会挂在你的脖子上。让我看看这个。让我看看这个。我太喜欢了。你知道吗？
I purposely didn't put the million because like kind of like with the cake.
If you know, you know.
If you know you know.
And there's going to be some school assembly, Jenna.
You're going to be sitting there.
And someone's going to be like, 500.
Huh.
And you're going to be like, uh-huh.
我故意没有加上“百万”，因为就像蛋糕一样。懂的自然懂。懂的自然懂。会有些学校集会，詹娜。你会坐在那里。会有人说，500。哼。然后你会说，嗯哼。
Yep.
That's right.
500.
500. And I would work 500 months. I bet that song stuck in my head. And I try to think of a way to like make it into downloads.
You almost did a song parody as well? I did. I gave up on that really quick.
Well, thank you for not giving up on these other celebratory items. I appreciate them very much.
You're welcome. Truly. I'm saying that sincerely. You're welcome. Sam, there's cake.
Great. I look forward to it. Congratulations. Congratulations. Well, you know, he's,
是的。没错。500。500。我会工作500个月。我敢打赌那首歌一直盘旋在我的脑海里。我试图想办法把它变成下载量。你差点也做了一个歌曲恶搞？我做了。我很快就放弃了。好吧，谢谢你没有放弃这些其他的庆祝物品。我非常感激。不客气。真的。我是真诚地说的。不客气。山姆，有蛋糕。太棒了。我很期待。恭喜。恭喜。你知道，他是，
Kidding this milestone has made us both really reflective on how it all began.
Yes, and there is a question that we have gotten a lot over the years that we've always wanted to answer,
and this week seemed like finally the perfect timing.
A lot of people have written in and asked how we started office ladies.
Yes, here's a letter from Rachel W. in Washington, D.C., Rachel says,
I'm very interested in hearing more about your thought and decision-making process that led to office ladies.
I just had my first baby and want to figure out a way to have a better balance between work and spending time with my family,
but it feels like there are so few options between full-time work or full-time at home.
庆祝这个里程碑让我们两人都对这一切是如何开始的进行了深刻的反思。是的，多年来我们收到了很多问题，我们一直很想回答，而本周似乎是完美的时机。很多人写信问我们是怎么开始做office ladies的。是的，这是华盛顿特区雷切尔·W的来信，雷切尔说，我非常想听听更多关于你们对促成office ladies的想法和决策过程。我刚生完第一个孩子，想找个方法在工作和花时间陪伴家人之间取得更好的平衡，但感觉全职工作或全职在家之间的选择太少了。
I love how you ladies figured out how to make work fit into your ideal work-life balance,
and I want to hear more about it.
And another letter from Paula M. in Monterey, Mexico.
Paula says, I recently got fired from a job I hated.
I've been working in the same industry for 15 plus years, and I want to try something new.
how did you guys find your ideal job?
Well, Rachel and Paula, we actually have a great story about how this podcast started.
And the reasons touch on some of the same themes that you mentioned in your letters about
我喜欢你们这些女士如何弄清楚如何让工作融入你们理想的工作与生活平衡中，我想听听更多关于它的信息。还有来自墨西哥蒙特雷的葆拉·M的另一封信。葆拉说，我最近被我讨厌的工作解雇了。我在同一个行业工作了15年以上，我想尝试一些新的东西。你们是怎么找到理想的工作的？好吧，雷切尔和葆拉，我们其实有一个关于这个播客是如何开始的绝佳故事。原因涉及到你们在信中提到的关于
wanting to find work-life balance and also wanting to try something new.
And Angela and I have shared a little bit about how podcasting came into our lives,
and we do write about it in our book, the Office BFFs.
But I would think that the main driving factor and tell me,
me if you agree with me here, Ann. But the main driving factor of how we got here is simply that
we always wanted to work together again. Ever since we wrapped the office, we've daydreamed
about working together again. Yeah. And I think we always assumed it would be an on-camera job,
like maybe we would host a game show or be in a TV show together again. And we talk about
想要找到工作与生活平衡以及想要尝试新事物的相同主题。安吉拉和我分享了一点关于播客是如何进入我们的生活的，我们在我们的书《Office BFFs》中写到了这一点。但我认为主要的驱动因素是——如果你同意我的观点的话，安。主要的驱动因素是我们如何走到这里的，很简单，我们一直想再次合作。自从我们拍完《办公室》后，我们就一直梦想着再次合作。是的。而且我想我们一直以为这将是一份出镜的工作，比如也许我们会主持一个游戏节目或者再次一起出现在电视节目中。我们一直在谈论
this all the time. And then about seven years ago, we were trading messages about how we wanted to
organize our garages and sheds. Sometimes you need a buddy to get this stuff done, right? You were like
my accountability buddy that I was finally going to get through all these bins because we had so much
junk that we were storing. And we had both been putting it off and putting it off. And I said,
let's pick a day and both get started. Because then that way we're kind of doing it together.
Yeah. And we would give each other little progress reports, you know? Exactly. It's very funny to me,
though that clearly seven years later, I had accumulated so much junk again that I had to
reclean my garage.
我们一直在谈论这个。大约七年前，我们在互发消息，讨论如何整理我们的车库和棚子。有时你需要一个朋友来把这些东西搞定，对吧？你就像我的监督伙伴，我终于要清理完所有这些箱子了，因为我们存放了太多的垃圾。我们俩都一直在拖延，拖延。我说，挑个日子，我们俩一起开始吧。因为这样我们就在一起做了。是的。我们会互相汇报一点进展，你知道吗？Exactly。不过我觉得很有趣的是，显然七年后，我又积累了那么多的垃圾，我不得不重新清理我的车库。
I can't even open my shed door.
Oh, no.
It's honestly one of the things Josh is like, I can't even walk past it.
Listen, seven years ago, these things were clean.
I know.
They were.
And mine is clean again.
So, lady, if you need help, I don't know what we'll get out of it.
我甚至打不开我的棚屋门。哦，不。老实说，乔治就是那种说，我甚至都不能从它旁边走过的人。听着，七年前，这些东西都是干净的。我知道。它们确实是。而我的又变干净了。所以，女士，如果你需要帮助，我不知道我们会从中得到什么。
But let's stay on track here.
While we were cleaning this stuff out, we both found a ton of office members.
memorabilia. We had these old photos. We had old scripts. We had old call sheets.
Yeah. Like all the stuff that we had saved for our whole nine years on the office.
I still had a bin of everything I kept in my trailer.
Mm-hmm. I had that too, labeled trailer. Yeah. I also had a ton of baskets and you had
broken lamps. Those are other things we tend to collect. I guess I love lamps. You love lamps? Even if
they're broken. I love baskets. But anyway, so we had all this office memorabilia.
但我们还是回到正题吧。在我们清理这些东西的时候，我们俩都找到了大量的办公室纪念品。我们有这些旧照片。我们有旧剧本。我们有旧通告单。是的。就像我们在《办公室》的整整九年里保存的所有东西一样。我仍然有一个箱子里装着我在拖车里保留的所有东西。嗯哼。我也有那个，上面标着拖车。是的。我还有大量的篮子，你还有坏掉的台灯。这些是我们倾向于收集的其他东西。我想我喜欢台灯。你喜欢台灯？即使它们坏了。我喜欢篮子。不管怎样，我们有所有的办公室纪念品。
we weren't really sure what to do with it.
And I told Jenna, maybe we should write a book.
And you said, hell no.
I'm never doing that again.
I think it was a more emphatic no.
Yeah.
It was a no.
我们真的不知道该拿它们怎么办。我告诉詹娜，也许我们应该写本书。你说，见鬼去吧。我再也不干那事了。我想这是一个更加坚决的“不”。是的。这是一个“不”。是的。
I was fresh off my first book.
And it, you know, it's a lot.
It's a lot.
By the way, when Josh wanted to do a book, I said hell no.
And then you did.
And then I did.
But anyway, I just thought we really needed to preserve our office stuff.
And we were trying to figure out how to do that.
我刚出过第一本书。而且，你知道，这很不容易。这很不简单。顺便说一句，当乔治想出一本书时，我说见鬼去吧。然后你写了。然后我写了。不管怎样，我只是觉得我们真的需要保存我们的办公室东西。我们当时在想怎么做。
Yeah, and I had this idea because one of the things that we both had a lot of were photos from Halloween episodes.
Yeah.
Because we often brought our cameras all nine years for any of the holiday episodes in particular.
They were always so much fun.
So I said, and why don't we go through all of our Halloween memorabilia from the office,
let's jot down some of our memories, and then we'll get together with one another and we'll read each other what we wrote.
We'll just like trade stories.
Yeah, and we had no idea what this was going to be.
是的，我当时有这个想法，因为我们俩都有很多东西，其中之一就是万圣节剧集的照片。是的。因为在所有九年的时间里，我们经常为任何万圣节剧集带上我们的相机。它们总是那么有趣。所以我说，安，我们为什么不翻阅一下我们所有的办公室万圣节纪念品，记下我们的一些回忆，然后我们聚在一起，互相朗读我们写的东西。我们就像是交换故事。是的，我们不知道这会变成什么样。
We just felt sort of compelled in this artist's journey to be like, we have this stuff.
Let's share about it.
Yeah, it was kind of like, how do we commit this stuff to memory before we don't remember it anymore?
Exactly.
So we did that.
And Jenna came over to my house.
We had just gone for a hike, lady.
It was your birthday.
我们只是觉得在这个艺术家的旅程中有一种冲动，好像在说，我们有这些东西。让我们分享一下吧。是的，这有点像是，在我们不再记得这些东西之前，我们怎么把它记在心里？没错。所以我们照做了。詹娜来到了我家。我们刚去徒步旅行回来，女士。那是你的生日。
Oh, yeah.
And we sat in my garage that we were in the process of converting into like a guest room
office. I remember Josh had just bought a sectional sofa from IKEA. So we actually had something
to sit on. And we decided to record this visit so we could have it saved for some future inspiration.
I basically took my iPhone and I just set it on the sofa between us and I hit the record button.
I also was eating a turkey wrap. I do remember. Sorry about that. You were. Yeah. And we just started
talking. Yeah. And we weren't thinking this was going to be anything. Like again, we were
just recording stories. But I just remember how much fun it was to sit and remember the office with
哦，是的。我们坐在我的车库里，我们当时正在把它改造成一个客房办公室。我还记得乔治刚刚从宜家买了一张转角沙发。所以我们实际上有地方坐了。我们决定把这次访问记录下来，这样我们就可以把它保存起来，作为将来的灵感。我基本上拿出我的iPhone，把它放在我们之间的沙发上，然后按下了录音键。我当时还在吃火鸡卷。我确实记得。真是不好意思。你吃了。是的。然后我们就开始聊天了。是的。我们当时并没有想过这会是什么。就像我说的，我们只是在记录故事。但我只记得坐在那里和你想起《办公室》是多么有趣
you. And then after I left your house, that was it. I was like, okay, what box are we going to clean out
next was all I was thinking? Yeah. I mean, I thought it was fun, but I also thought it was just fun having a
day with you. And I didn't know if we'd write a book or if we'd do anything. But because I had recorded
our hangout, we had that. I remember I texted you the audio file. I didn't even listen to it.
You didn't even listen. I didn't listen to it. Yeah. And then both of our husband,
were like, well, how'd it go today? And I remember telling Josh, well, it was really fun. I don't know,
you know, what it is. And he was like, well, I'd love to hear it. So he listens to it. And he finds me
later that evening. I'm in the kitchen. And he comes in and he's like, Ange, this is great. Like,
然后在我离开你家之后，就是这样。当时我脑子里想的只有，好吧，我们接下来要清理哪个箱子？是的。我的意思是，我觉得很有趣，但我也觉得和你一起度过一天很有趣。我不知道我们会不会写书或者做别的什么。但因为我录下了我们的聚会，我们有了这个。我记得我把音频文件发短信给你了。我甚至都没听。你甚至都没听。我没听。是的。然后我们两个人的丈夫都问，今天怎么样？我记得告诉乔治，嗯，这真的很有趣。我不知道，你知道，这是什么。他说，嗯，我很想听听。于是他听了。那天晚上晚些时候他找到了我。我在厨房里。他走进来对我说，安吉，这太棒了，像，
I think this could be a podcast or something. Yeah. And you told me that. Yeah. So then I said,
Lee, will you listen to this thing we recorded? Because Josh thinks it could be a podcast. So Lee listened to it.
he was like, yes, oh my gosh, this is a podcast.
He said, my friend Jeff should listen to this.
He said his friend Jeff knew a lot about podcasting.
So I'm like, okay, so we email it to Jeff, not knowing that Jeff was Jeff Ulrich,
one of the founders of Earwolf.
He's like the Steve Jobs of podcasting, basically.
我觉得这可以做成一个播客什么的。是的。你告诉过我这个。是的。所以我就说，李，你会听我们录下的这段东西吗？因为乔治觉得这可以成为一个播客。所以李听了。他说，是的，哦天哪，这是一个播客。他说，我的朋友杰夫应该听听这个。他说他的朋友杰夫对播客了解很多。所以我想，好吧，我们就把它发邮件给杰夫，当时并不知道杰夫就是杰夫·乌尔里希，Earwolf的创始人之一。他基本上就是播客界的史蒂夫·乔布斯。
So Jeff listened to it.
He agreed.
And he said, do you want to meet with some people?
And he eventually introduced us to a lot of people in the podcasting world.
You know what I remember?
What?
We went to his house and we were talking about it with him.
And you kept saying, but where do we plug in the microphones?
所以杰夫听了，他同意了。他说，你想不想和一些人见见面？然后他最终把播客界的很多人介绍给了我们。你知道我记得什么吗？什么？我们去了他家，跟他讨论这件事。而你一直说，但是我们要把麦克风插在哪里？
I was like, how do you get the microphones for it?
Where do you get the microphones?
Because we recorded this on our iPhone, but like we'll need regular microphones.
You were so curious about the production from the very beginning.
And he was like, I don't want to talk about the microphones.
Like, that'll happen.
He's like, I'm talking about a vision for what this could be to you.
And I'm like, yeah, I know.
我当时就想，怎么弄到麦克风？去哪儿弄麦克风？因为我们是用iPhone录的，但我们需要那种普通的麦克风。你从一开始就对制作过程充满好奇。而他说，我不想谈麦克风的事。这以后会有的。他说，我在跟你谈论这可能成为什么的愿景。我说，对，我懂。
I guess I just am wondering like,
Where do you?
How do you upload it?
Well, you always said, and I love this, you were like, don't be afraid to ask a lot of dumb questions
because we were learning a whole new genre.
This was an absolute big career pivot, and we didn't know what we were doing.
Yeah, and we had the benefit of our name value, right?
Like, that's something and that is valuable.
我想我只是在想，你把文件放哪？你怎么上传？好吧，你总是说，我特别喜欢这个，你说，不要害怕问很多愚蠢的问题，因为我们在学习一个全新的流派。这是一个绝对重大的职业转型，我们根本不知道自己在做什么。对，而且我们占了名字知名度的便宜，对吧？就像，那是一种资产，也是有价值的。
And we had our true life memories of working on this show and our friendships with the cast and crew.
But otherwise, this was a whole new section of the entertainment industry.
we didn't know anything about it.
And so we did.
We went out there.
We made ourselves vulnerable.
We asked a lot of dumb questions and a lot of meetings.
But the more we looked at it, the more podcasting really made sense because it was a stable job in Los Angeles, which is not easy to come by in the entertainment industry.
我们有在这个节目中工作的真实生活记忆，以及我们与演员和剧组的友谊。但除此之外，这是娱乐产业的一个全新领域，我们对此一无所知。所以我们去做了。我们让自己变得脆弱。我们在许多会议上问了很多愚蠢的问题。但我们越是深入了解，就越觉得播客真的很有意义，因为这是洛杉矶的一份稳定工作，在娱乐产业里这可不容易找到。
We would be able to set our own schedules, which was very important to us.
It was something we could do while our kids were at school.
It just, it really seemed like it could open up a whole new lifestyle for us.
and then of course, best of all, we could work together again in a creative way.
Yeah.
It was best friendship and putting family first.
And that's how we got here and cleaning out our garages and sheds, which makes me say, lady, what could happen on the next big clean?
I don't know.
我们可以自己安排时间，这对我们非常重要。这是我们能在孩子们上学期间做的事情。它真的看起来能为我们开启一种全新的生活方式。然后当然，最棒的是，我们可以再次以富有创造力的方式合作。是的。这是最棒的友谊，也是把家庭放在首位。我们就是这样走到这一步的，还要清理我们的车库和杂物间，这让我想说，女士们，下一次大扫除会发生什么？我不知道。
What's in there?
You know, I hadn't listened to this recording since we did it.
It's been seven years.
Yeah.
It's a pretty crazy time capsule of.
where we were in life and I'm so glad we have it. You know, Josh, after we recorded it and we decided
to kind of use it as a sizzle to take meetings, he sort of tidied it up. He did. There was, I think,
40 seconds of me unwrapping a turkey wrap. He took that out. Yeah. And he added like some
里面有什么？你知道，自从我们录制这个录音以来，我再没听过。已经七年了。是的。这是一个相当疯狂的时间胶囊，记录了我们当时的人生处境，我很高兴我们拥有它。你知道，乔什，在我们录完之后，我们决定用它作为推介会议的短片，他稍微整理了一下。他确实整理了。我想当时有40秒是我在拆火鸡卷包装的声音。他把那个剪掉了。是的。他还加了一些
little musical stings and it's just wild to hear again, isn't it? It really is. And we kind of thought
that we could play it for y'all today in honor of reaching 500 million downloads.
We thank you so much for being on this journey with us.
And 100% there is no office ladies without this community.
And you guys are the 500 million downloads.
It's you.
You're the reason we're here.
You're the reason why we get to be at our kids' soccer games and we get to work with
小音乐音效，再次听到真的太疯狂了，对吧？确实是这样。我们觉得今天可以在大家达到5亿下载量之际放给你们听。非常感谢你们一路陪伴我们。100%如果没有这个社区，就不会有“办公室女士”这个播客。而你们就是那5亿次的下载量。就是你们。你们是我们来到这里的理由。你们是我们能够去看孩子们的足球比赛，并且能够和
each other's best friends again.
And we just love you guys from the bottom of our hearts.
And I guess also I would say to Rachel and Paula, in answer to your questions, starting something new, particularly a new career, it takes a big leap of faith. And you have to be willing to risk being a beginner at something again. You have to be willing to look stupid and to not know everything. It can be a very humbling thing to start something new. And that's another reason why we wanted to play this for you so that you can see where we started. Because it is not perfect. Oh, no, not at all.
far from perfect, but it was the start of something. It's the very beginning for us. It was a spark,
you know, and what we've learned in our careers is you've got to lean into that creative spark
and see where it takes you. So let's take a quick break. And when we come back, it is our
office ladies pilot that we didn't even know was going to be our pilot that we've never shared
before. Okay, this is March 7th. It is Jenna's birthday. She is 45 today. I am.
彼此最好的朋友再次共事的理由。我们从心底里爱你们。我想我还想对瑞秋和宝拉说，回答你们的问题：开始做一件新事，尤其是开启一项新职业，需要迈出巨大的一步。你必须愿意再次承担成为新手的风险。你必须愿意看起来很傻，并且不是什么都知道。开始一件新事是非常考验人的一件事。这也是我们想把这个放给你们听的另一个原因，这样你们就能看到我们是从哪里起步的。因为它并不完美。哦，不，一点也不。离完美还差得远，但这是一个开始。这是我们的最初起点。这是一个火花，你知道的，我们在职业生涯中学到的是，你必须顺应那个创意火花，看看它会把你带向何方。所以我们先休息一下。等我们回来，就是我们的“办公室女士”试播集了，我们甚至不知道它会成为我们的试播集，而且我们从未分享过。好的，今天是3月7日。今天是珍娜的生日。她今天45岁了。我...
We just went on a hike for her birthday.
And now we are sitting in what was once my rundown garage that we have made into my office.
Office slash guest room slash pool house slash kid hangout.
And Jen and I are really excited.
This is the first time we are going to read some of our pages out loud together.
While Jenna reads, she's going first.
I am eating a turkey wrap and chips and salsa, so I hope that's not annoying.
Well, I'm just really excited to listen to this later and transcribe it and hear your chip.
我们刚刚为她的生日去徒步旅行了。现在我们坐在曾经是我那破旧的车库里，我们把它改造成了办公室。办公室兼客房兼泳池房兼儿童活动室。珍和我都非常兴奋。这是我们第一次一起大声朗读我们的一些剧本。珍娜朗读时，她先来。我正在吃火鸡卷、薯片和莎莎酱，所以我希望这不会太烦人。好吧，我真的很期待稍后听这个录音并把它转录下来，还能听到你嚼薯片的声音。
I think that is going to be a really fun time.
for me. It's like give that keeps on giving to them. All right. So it was my job to dive deep into the
Halloween episodes, not just the Halloween episodes, but just Halloween in general on the office,
because it was a very special time. It was. We had a lot of fun. And I was thinking about why.
Why was it such a very special, highly anticipated holiday on the set of the office? Well,
first of all, Pam always had candy on her desk. And one of my favorite candies personally,
is candy corn.
You love candy corn.
我觉得对我来说这会是一段非常有趣的时光。这就像是源源不断的礼物。好的。所以我的工作是深入研究万圣节剧集，不仅是万圣节剧集，还有《办公室》里关于万圣节的一切，因为这是一个非常特别的时刻。确实是的。我们玩得很开心。我在想为什么。为什么它在《办公室》片场会是一个如此特别、备受期待的节日呢？好吧，首先，潘的桌上总是放着糖果。我个人最喜欢的糖果之一是玉米糖。你很喜欢玉米糖。
I'm eating.
And they would put candy corn in my candy dish the week that we shot the Halloween episodes.
And the first year they did it, I ate so much of it.
And I think the props people were so annoyed with me because they had to keep refilling
that dish for continuity.
And then I actually got sick.
I actually got a stomachache from eating too much candy.
I was like a child.
我在吃。他们会在我们拍摄万圣节剧集的那个星期把玉米糖放在我的糖果盘里。他们这样做的第一年，我吃了太多。我想道具组对我很恼火，因为为了连戏，他们不得不一直给那个盘子补货。然后我真的生病了。我因为吃太多糖而胃痛。我当时就像个小孩子。
It was like what our parents tell us.
Yeah.
It don't make you sick.
It did.
But it was just right.
there. So I was thinking about besides the candy corn, why did we love it so much? And I thought about it.
Our regular wardrobe was so routine. Every character basically had a uniform. Like Dwight had
mustard shirts. Pam was pastel cardigans and pencil skirts. Angela, you were just high necks and gray.
就像父母对我们说的那样。是的。别吃得让自己生病。确实生病了。但它就摆在那里。所以我在想，除了玉米糖，我们为什么那么喜欢它？我想了想。我们日常的戏服太常规了。每个角色基本上都有制服。比如德怀特穿芥末黄衬衫。潘则是粉蜡色开衫和铅笔裙。安吉拉，你总是穿高领和灰色。
Gray, charcoal. I literally have a line where I say, I improvised that I was so proud of that they were
like, Amy Adams was like, what's your favorite color? And I said gray, charcoal, shades of gray. Shades of
Great.
Phyllis basically just dressed in purple.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
Or a tiger print.
Oh, no, leopard print.
灰色，炭灰色。我真的有一句台词，我即兴发挥的台词，我为此感到无比自豪，他们……安妮·海瑟薇（注：此处原文提及艾米·亚当斯，属口误或ASR识别瑕疵，保持直译）就像是，你最喜欢什么颜色？我说灰色，炭灰色，各种灰度。各种灰度。菲利斯基本上只穿紫色。嗯哼。对吧？或者豹纹。哦，不，豹纹。
Leopard print?
Animal print or purple.
At least Andy got the preppy plaids.
An interesting belt.
He always had some real...
So many belts.
Interesting belt.
And if you think about it, our hairstyle never really changed either.
豹纹？动物纹或者紫色。至少安迪穿了学院风格子。还有一条有趣的皮带。他总是戴着一些真的……好多皮带。有趣的皮带。如果你想想，我们的发型其实也从来没变过。
So I feel like we just really craved any chance to break out.
And Halloween was the chance.
Oh, it was a big chance.
It was a huge...
It wasn't just a slight breakout.
It was a huge breakout.
Huge breakout.
It was like the most.
所以我觉得我们真的渴望任何能够突破的机会。而万圣节就是这个机会。哦，这是一个绝佳的机会。这是一个巨大的……这不仅仅是小幅突破。这是一个巨大的突破。巨大的突破。这简直是
exciting thing to happen to the wardrobe department, to the hair and makeup department.
Everyone was very excited. And, you know, it was equal among genders. I remember Rain getting so
excited about his costumes. So sometimes people ask me if we ever had any say and what our
characters dressed as for Halloween. And the very simple answer to that is no. Absolutely not.
Absolutely not. So many of our costumes were plot related. There was like the joke that you could
wear the same white cat costume year after year even when you were pregnant, which is a very funny
snarky scene that we have.
Or the time that Creed, Dwight and Kevin all dresses the Joker.
服装部发生的最令人兴奋的事情，对发型和化妆部也是如此。每个人都非常兴奋。而且，你知道，这在性别上是平等的。我记得雷恩对他的服装感到非常兴奋。所以有时候人们问我，对于万圣节我们角色的穿着，我们是否有发言权。最简单的回答是：没有。绝对没有。绝对没有。我们的许多服装都与剧情相关。比如那个笑话，你可以年复一年地穿着同样的白色猫咪服装，甚至在你怀孕的时候也是如此，这是我们拍过的一个非常搞笑、刻薄的场景。或者有一次，克里德、德怀特和凯文都打扮成小丑。
Or the time when Pam dressed as Charlie Chaplin, just to find out she was the only person
to dress up in a costume at her new job.
That was when she was off at art school.
And then she couldn't take off her hat because then she looked like Hitler.
Yes.
So the costume choices were mostly dictated by the story that the writer wanted to tell.
That happened to be on Halloween.
But I feel like there was one exception.
或者有一次，潘打扮成查理·卓别林，结果发现自己是新工作中唯一一个盛装打扮的人。那是她在艺术学校的时候。然后她摘不下帽子，因为那样她看起来就像希特勒。是的。所以服装的选择主要是由编剧想要讲述的故事决定的。那个故事刚好发生在万圣节。但我觉得有一个例外。
Do you know who I'm thinking of?
Oh my God.
Can I guess?
Yes. Mindy Kaling? Yes. Mindy Kaling.
Mindy was also on the writing staff. She got to be part of picking her own costume and she always,
well, Mindy loves to dress up. Like she loves to go big, right?
Yes, she does. And she had the best costume. She was Carrie Bradshaw. She was Snooky,
Katie Perry and then Leloo from the Fifth Element. And I have this picture of you and Mindy.
你知道我在想谁吗？天哪。我能猜吗？可以。敏迪·卡灵？是的。敏迪·卡灵。敏迪也是编剧团队的一员。她可以参与挑选自己的服装，而且她总是，嗯，敏迪喜欢盛装打扮。就像她喜欢搞得很大阵仗，对吧？是的，她确实如此。而且她有最棒的服装。她扮演过凯莉·布拉德肖。她扮演过思琪、凯蒂·佩里，还有《第五元素》里的勒露。我有一张你和敏迪的照片。
You weren't like a black widow. I took my camera that day. That's a cold open we shot.
Yeah. I didn't get used. Yes. And she was Lilo.
and like she had a multipass.
Lillumatupia.
Multi-pass.
Lillumptipas.
You haven't seen in Fidelma?
Uh-uh.
你当时不是穿得像个黑寡妇吗？我那天带了相机。那是我们拍的一个片头。是的。没被采用。是的。她当时扮演勒露。就像她有一个多重通行证。勒露，多重通行证。多重通行证。勒露，多重通行证。你没看过《第五元素》？呃-呃。
Jenna, this is a great movie,
and I think it still holds up.
I'm just going to say that.
Lillow Matipas.
What does that mean?
Are you saying her last name?
Are you saying Lelu has a multi-pass?
Like, she's going to a...
珍娜，这是一部很棒的电影，而且我觉得它至今不过时。我只想这么说。勒露，多重通行证。那是什么意思？你是在说她的姓吗？你是说勒露有一个多重通行证？就像，她要去……
She's going to outer space,
and you have to have this multipast to get on this ship.
Is it like a metro car?
Kind of.
Oh, you have to see this.
Bruce Willis is in it.
I do love Bruce Willis.
Chris Tucker's in it.
她要去外太空，你必须有这个多重通行证才能上飞船。这就像地铁卡吗？差不多。哦，你一定要看看这个。布鲁斯·威利斯在里面。我确实很喜欢布鲁斯·威利斯。克里斯·塔克在里面。
But this.
Lilu costume was basically white gauze.
So much skin.
Yes, well, you have to see it because she's in like this.
Oh God, I don't even know how to explain it.
But she is the fifth element.
Okay.
Lilu.
但这个。勒露的服装基本上就是白色纱布。露出了好多皮肤。是的，好吧，你得亲自看看，因为她穿着这种。天哪，我甚至不知道该怎么解释。但她就是第五元素。好吧。勒露。
So I guess Mindy Kaling and I was right.
Mindy Kaling.
I want to talk about one of my personal favorite episodes of The Office, which also happens
to be our very first Halloween episode.
Okay.
It aired during season two and was called appropriately, Halloween.
I cry at the end every time I watch it.
So the plot is very simple.
所以我想是敏迪·卡灵，我猜对了。敏迪·卡灵。我想聊聊《办公室》里我个人最喜欢的剧集之一，它恰好也是我们的第一个万圣节剧集。好的。它在第二季播出，名字很应景，就叫《万圣节》。每次我看的时候，到了结尾我都会哭。所以剧情非常简单。
if you don't remember, Michael is told that he must fire someone during the month of October due to cutbacks at Dunder Mifflin.
But in true Michael fashion, he waits until the very last day of October, which also happens to be Halloween.
Greg Daniels wrote this episode, and I remember him telling me that the inspiration for the episode was that he had always wanted to do a story about someone being fired,
but from the point of view of the boss rather than the employee.
He said, we always see stories of the people being fired, but rarely stories about the person having to do the firing.
And I always thought that Greg's decision to set the story on Halloween when everyone is dressed up and excited for office Halloween party made the whole thing even more delightfully uncomfortable to watch.
Oh, so tragic.
Like, no one wants to get fired when they're dressed up like a clown or something.
如果你不记得了，迈克尔被告知由于邓德·米夫林公司的精简开支，他必须在10月份开除一个人。但带有典型的迈克尔风格，他一直拖到10月的最后一天，而那天恰好也是万圣节。格雷格·丹尼尔斯写了这一集，我记得他告诉我这集的灵感来源是，他一直想做一个关于某人被解雇的故事，但视角是从老板而不是员工的角度出发的。他说，我们总是看到被解雇之人的故事，但很少看到必须执行解雇之人的故事。我一直认为，格雷格将故事设定在万圣节这个每个人都盛装打扮、为办公室万圣节派对感到兴奋的日子的决定，让整个情境在观看时变得加倍地令人尴尬、难受。哦，太悲剧了。就好像，当人们打扮得像小丑或者别的什么的时候，谁都不想被解雇。
It's depressing.
But the one problem that this plot presented for Greg was that he would actually have to fire someone on the show.
And he didn't want to fire any of the core cast members, even though many of the supporting characters at this time were still under weekly contracts.
You guys were not considered series regulars yet.
Oh, no, not at all.
You know how you say you have a photo of the exact moment you knew we'd be best friends?
Yes.
I have a photo of the exact moment I was made series regular.
这太令人沮丧了。但这个情节给格雷格带来的唯一问题是，他必须在剧里真正开除一个人。而他不想解雇任何核心演员，尽管当时许多配角仍然签着周薪合同。你们当时还不被认为是剧中的常规演员。哦，不，一点也不。你知道你为什么说你有一张照片，记录了你知道我们会成为最好朋友的那一刻吗？是的。我有一张照片，记录了我成为常规演员的那一刻。
And you and I are jumping up and down.
Giddy, holding hands, jumping up and down because I got the news while we were on Boos Cruz.
That's when we became series regulars.
But this was before Boos Cruz.
Yes.
So he could have any of us fired any of you guys, but he didn't want to.
But he also didn't want to hire a new person just for one episode, establish them, and fire them because it felt dishonest.
Like, it felt, he said it felt like cheating.
而你和我都在蹦蹦跳跳。兴奋得手拉着手蹦跳，因为我们在乘“布斯游轮”时得到了消息。那是我们成为常规演员的时候。但这发生在“布斯游轮”之前。是的。所以他本可以解雇我们中的任何一个人，你们中的任何人，但他不想这样做。但他也不想仅仅为了某一集去雇一个新角色，让他们建立人设然后再解雇他们，因为这感觉很不真诚。就像，他觉得这感觉像是在作弊。
So he had to fire someone we'd already seen on the show.
So we had two stand-ins at the time, and maybe we should tell people what a stand-in is.
A stand-in is a person who fills in for the actor after the rehearsal of a scene while the crew adjusts the lights.
They walk where the actor would walk or sit or stand where the actor would sit or stand during the scene,
and the crew figures out where to put the cameras in the light.
And then when it's time for the camera to roll, the actors are called back to the set and begin shooting the scene.
So we had two stand-ins.
They were Creed and Devon.
所以他必须解雇一个我们已经在剧中见过的演员。当时我们有两个替身，也许我们应该告诉大家什么是替身。替身是在一场戏排练完、剧组调整灯光时，代替演员走位的人。他们会在场景中模仿演员走位、坐下或站立，以便剧组确定摄像机和灯光的位置。当摄像机开始拍摄时，演员会被叫回片场开始拍摄。所以我们当时有两个替身。他们是克里德和德文。
And both Creed and Devon had also appeared on camera in the background of some conference room scenes or in the annex by the break room.
Maybe they would like cross in the deep background of a scene like they were delivering mail.
I remember we had that mail cart that really made no sense because we didn't have a mail room.
But whatever.
But they'd never spoken.
They've been established so that was enough for Greg.
But then Greg, who is the gentlest man, had the dilemma of picking who to fire, Creed or Devin.
I can't imagine how that weighed on Greg, because he really is just a kind, kind-hearted person, and it just must have erect him.
克里德和德文都曾在某些会议室或休息室旁边的走廊背景中出镜。也许他们会像送信一样在场景的极深背景中走过。我记得我们有个根本说不通的信件推车，因为我们根本没有收发室。但无所谓了。不过他们从未说过台词。他们已经露过面了，对格雷格来说这就够了。但后来，格雷格这个最温和的人，却面临着抉择：是解雇克里德还是德文。我无法想象这在格雷格心中分量有多重，因为他真的是个心地极其善良的人，这肯定把他折磨惨了。
So Greg spoke with both of them, and he found out that Devin had just been cast in an off-Broadway play in New York.
So this was all Greg needed to hear.
He decided Devin would be fired.
since he had this job to go to.
And Creed went from being a non-speaking stand-in in our show
to getting a five-page scene with Steve Carell.
No audition.
Greg had never seen him act,
于是格雷格找他们两人谈了话，他发现德文刚刚在纽约接了一部百老汇外卡剧。这就是格雷格需要听到的全部信息。他决定解雇德文，因为他有这份工作要去。而克里德从我们剧中的一个无台词替身，一跃得到了与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔演对手戏的五页长台词。没有试镜。格雷格从未看过他演戏，
handed him a five-page scene with Steve Carell.
The scene was so popular with fans,
and Greg was so delighted,
that he started writing more stuff for Creed,
and then Creed eventually also became a series regular.
Yes.
And it was all because Greg needed someone to fire.
So in addition to this being the episode
直接交给他一份与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔演对手戏的五页台词。这一幕在粉丝中大受欢迎，格雷格也感到非常高兴，于是他开始为克里德写更多戏份，最终克里德也成了常规演员。是的。这一切都只是因为格雷格需要找个人解雇。所以，除了这一集
that launched Creed into the All-Eard,
into the office family, it is responsible for a number of first.
This is the episode that features Jim and Pam's first air high-five.
Aw, Jam! Jam Air High Five!
It is also the first time Pam is seen wearing her hair down rather than half-up, half-down,
which I call the Pam Mullet, and it was a huge debate about whether or not this hair change could be
allowed. It went several rounds with the producers and writers before being approved.
Would Pam look too cute if she wore her hair down?
将克里德带入了办公室大家庭，它还创造了许多“第一”。这一集是吉姆和帕姆第一次在空中击掌。哦，杰姆！杰姆空中击掌！这也是帕姆第一次被看到把头发放下来，而不是半扎不扎，我管它叫“帕姆鲻鱼头”，大家对这种发型改变是否被允许展开了巨大的争论。在获得批准之前，它和制片人以及编剧进行了几轮讨论。如果帕姆把头发放下来，会不会显得太可爱了？
They decided to go for it.
And then the next time you see a hair change from Pam is Casino Night.
I mean, if we know a lot of details about hair and stuff like that,
is because these were huge discussions.
We just always wanted to stay true to the integrity of who these people were
and not as the success of the show grew, like, jizzed them up too much.
They were still in Scranton in a paper company,
even though the show was gaining more popularity,
他们决定试一试。然后你下一次看到帕姆换发型就是“赌场之夜”了。我的意思是，如果我们知道很多关于头发之类的细节，那是因为这些都是经过激烈讨论的。我们只是总是想保持这些人物身份的纯粹性，随着剧集的成功，不要把他们打扮得太花哨。他们仍然在斯克兰顿的一家造纸公司上班，尽管这部剧越来越受欢迎，
and we were sort of becoming a little bit like,
I don't know, like fancier.
Well, this was true of wardrobe as well.
They only shopped at places that our characters could realistically afford to shop at.
So if Pam had to wear a pair of jeans, I wore a pair of jeans from the gap.
I did not wear a pair of $200 designer jeans.
Right.
And also, our wardrobe department was amazing.
而我们变得有点像，我不知道，有点更华丽了。服装也是如此。他们只在我们的角色能够实际负担得起的地方买衣服。所以如果帕姆得穿一条牛仔裤，我就穿Gap的牛仔裤。我没有穿两百美元的设计师牛仔裤。没错。而且，我们的服装部门太棒了。
You know, they made sure, like, your pants weren't too long or things like that,
but they did not fit you, like alter things the way most TV shows do.
And after the office, I worked on a show called Your Family or My Home.
mine and the women that did the wardrobe also did the wardrobe for friends and those women
looked amazing on friends and I have never looked so cabam like ever in my life they altered it
every everything they altered like where your shoulder hymn is and where like the end like
everything fit me like a glove yeah most shows tailor clothes to your body yeah and that's why
everybody looks so fabulous on TV they said to me do you know what's the difference between just a
你知道，他们确保你的裤子不会太长诸如此类的，但他们不会像大多数电视剧那样为你量身修改衣服。在《办公室》之后，我参演了一部名为《你的家还是我的家》的剧，负责服装的女性也曾为《老友记》做服装，那些女性在《老友记》里看起来美极了，而我这辈子从来没有看起来这么惊艳过，她们修改了一切，她们修改了肩缝的位置以及末端，每件衣服都像量身定制一样合身，是的，大多数电视剧都会为你的身材定制衣服，这就是为什么每个人在电视上看起来都那么棒，她们对我说，你知道普通人走在街上和电视上的人走在街上有什么区别吗？我说什么？她们说，是修改衣服。这百分之百是真的。因为大多数人知道怎么把头发吹蓬松，化一点妆。但是有这样合身的衣服。她们震惊了，因为我说，哦天哪，看看这件衣服多合身。哦，你要把它收进去。你要缝这个。她们说，安吉拉，你在《办公室》里从来没修改过衣服吗？我说，呃，没有。没有。因为我们要让那个世界看起来很真实。关于万圣节的另一件事是，人们在万圣节会打扮成我们办公室里的角色。我太喜欢了。
normal person walking down the street and someone walking down the street on a TV show.
And I said what? And they said alterations. It's 100% true. Because most people like figure out
how to blow out their hair and put a little bit of makeup on. But having clothes fit you like that.
And they were blown away because I was like, oh my gosh, look how this fits me. Oh, you're going to
take that in. You're going to sew this. And they're like, Angela, have you never had your clothes
altered on the office? I was like, uh, no. No. Because we had to look realistic for that world.
Another thing about Halloween is people dress up as our office characters for Halloween on Halloween.
Which I love so much.
这太疯狂了，对吧？当我被标记为怀特和安吉拉时，我太喜欢了。你是一个万圣节服装。我还想说，在我收到的所有照片中，我认为最受欢迎、我看到最多的，是帕姆版猫咪和三孔打孔器吉姆。是的。这是我收到最多的。我看到自己穿着阿盖尔毛衣，通常女孩们头上戴着发带或梳着大背头，她们都抱着一只毛绒猫。
Which is crazy, right?
When I get tagged as White and Angela, I love it so much.
You are a Halloween costume.
I also want to say that of all the photos that I get, I think that the most popular, the one I see the most, is the Pam Cat Three Hole Punch Gym.
Yeah.
That's the one I get the most.
I get just myself in an Argyll sweater with usually the girls have their hair in a hair.
headband or slick back pony and they're all holding a cat stuffed animal.
我看到很多女孩穿着白猫衣服。另一个第一次是，这个万圣节剧集是自从我们的试播集以来，英国原版《办公室》的创作者斯蒂芬·麦钱特和瑞奇·热维斯第一次访问我们的片场。是的。他们呆了几乎一整天。有一天我们在拍摄时，我们都兴奋得不得了。在他们离开之前，我请求和他们以及该剧的一些美国制片人合影。但我是照片中唯一一个明显穿着万圣节服饰的人。
I get a lot where girls are wearing the white cats.
Another first, this Halloween episode was the first time since our pilot that the creators
of the original British series of the office, Stephen Merchant and Ricky Jervais, visited our set.
Yes.
They stayed almost an entire day.
One day when we were filming, we were all geeking out.
Before they left, I asked for a photo with them and some of the American producers of the show.
But I am the only person in the photo who is obviously dressed in a Halloween costume.
你有这张照片吗？是的。你大概能看出吉姆身上有三孔打孔器的其中一个圆圈。是的。当我看着这张照片时，我喜欢想象我当时正在排演一出关于猫的学校话剧，所有这些人都来看我演出，我在后台摆姿势拍照。是的，那是你的猫咪话剧后台。在我的猫咪话剧里。
Do you have it?
Yes.
You can kind of see like Jim has like one circle of his three hole punch.
When I look at the photo, I like to imagine that I was doing like a school play about a cat
and all these people came to see me and I pose for a picture backstage.
Yeah, that's backstage at your cat play.
At my cat play.
是的。这是我关于瑞奇·热维斯的一个故事。他们在片场。我们对此都感到有点紧张。我当时还没怎么拍过戏，但在午饭后，我有一场采访镜头。我穿过午餐区，看到了瑞奇·热维斯，并被介绍认识了他。瑞奇实际上现在要回视频村了，因为他要从午餐一直看到一天结束的画面。
Yeah.
Here's my one story about Ricky Dervase.
So they were on set.
We were all kind of nervous about it.
And I hadn't really been in scenes yet.
but after lunch, I had a talking hedge.
And I come through the lunch area and I see Ricky Jervase and I'm introduced to him.
Ricky's actually going back to Video Village now because he's going to watch everything from lunch on to the end of day.
而你成了他们开始看的第一个人？我说，太棒了。他们说，安吉拉，你是第一个。我说，哦，太棒了。我看着瑞奇·热维斯，他说，别担心，我咂嘴不会太大声。这就是他对我说的话。出于所有这些原因，我很喜欢这个第一个万圣节剧集，但我尤其喜欢结局。我不知道你是否还记得结局，但结局是迈克尔给小孩子们发糖，我每次看都会哭。
And you were the first thing you started watching?
And I was like, great.
And they were like, Angela, you're first up.
And I said, oh, fantastic.
And I look to Ricky Jervase and he goes, don't worry, I don't tisk too loudly.
And that's what he said to me.
For all of these reasons, I love this first Halloween episode, but I especially love the end.
And I don't know if you remember the end, but at the end, Michael hands out candy to little kids, and I cry every time.
我想着这个都要哽咽了。我记得当时对于最后一个镜头该如何呈现有过一场激烈的辩论。大家讨论孩子们是对迈克尔好一点，还是觉得他很烦人，因为他在发糖时会讲笑话。编剧和制片人们还讨论了史蒂夫在发糖时应该是开心还是难过。最终决定，他们会从迈克尔的一个窥视镜头开始，他看起来又伤心又孤独，独自一人坐在屋里，在万圣节的夜晚。他刚刚解雇了某个人。然后你听到门铃响了，当他走到门前看到孩子们时，他眼前一亮，讲起了傻里傻气的笑话，孩子们只是开怀大笑，为他感到高兴，他建立了这种联系。
I'm getting choked up thinking about it.
I remember there was a big debate over how that final moment should be played out.
There was a discussion as to whether or not the kids should be nice to Michael or if they should be annoyed by him, because he was going to be cracking jokes while he handed out candy.
and the writers and producers also discussed if Steve should be happy or sad while handing out the candy.
It was decided that they would start on the spy shot of Michael looking sad and lonely inside of his house, alone on Halloween night.
He's just fired someone.
Then you hear the doorbell, and when he gets to the door and sees the kids, he lights up, he makes his silly jokes,
and the kids just laugh and laugh and are delighted by him, and he makes this connection.
我在哭。是的。这真是太美丽、太善良、太让人心碎了。正是这样的时刻让《办公室》变得如此特别。我们可以整整一集都在嘲笑迈克尔·斯科特，或者觉得他很烦人，但到头来，他会用他的善良和脆弱击碎你的心。以及他想要得到我们所有人想要的东西的渴望，那就是去爱并被爱。是的。
I'm crying.
Yeah.
And it's just beautiful and kind and heartbreaking.
And it's moments like this that make the office so special.
We can spend an entire episode laughing at Michael Scott or fighting him annoying,
but in the end, he will break your heart with his kindness and vulnerability.
And his desire to have what we all want, which is just to love and be loved in return.
Yes.
这太让人心碎、太甜蜜、太真实了，不是吗？这就像是一个如此诚实的时刻。我想这就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯在我们的节目中如此伟大的地方。就是找到这些如此真实的现实生活瞬间。你必须明白，解雇一个人对迈克尔来说是如此艰难，因为他只想被人喜欢。而这个功能失调的办公室大家庭确实是他的家庭。让他回家的选择真是太棒了
And that is heartbreaking and so sweet and so real, isn't it?
It's just like such an honest moment.
I think that's what I think Greg Daniels was so great at in our show.
is finding these just real life moments that were so honest.
And you've got to know firing someone was so hard for Michael
because all he wanted to do was be liked.
And this dysfunctional office family was truly his family.
It was such a great choice to have him go home
然后你就会明白为什么他在工作时需求那么强。是的。你知道。他太孤独了。他就是太孤独了。我喜欢孩子们为他感到高兴。史蒂夫用他的脸做了一个动作。他看起来就像内心被点亮了一样。
and you see why he's so needy at work.
Yes.
You know.
He's so lonely.
He's just so lonely.
And I loved that the kids delighted in him.
And there was this thing that Steve did with his face.
He just looked like lit up inside.
你知道，当他们笑的时候，你看到那种喜悦涌上迈克尔的面庞。哦，太甜了。如果我们有机会拍一集重聚剧集，我只需要看到迈克尔·斯科特和他的孩子在一起。是的，他是最棒的爸爸。最棒的爸爸。是的。他的孩子觉得他就是一切。是的，没错。
You know, when they laughed, you saw that joy come over Michael.
Oh, it was so sweet.
If we ever get to do a reunion episode, I just need to see Michael Scott with his kid.
Yes, and he's the best dad.
The best dad.
Yes.
And his kid just thinks he is everything.
Yeah, exactly.
他和霍莉都很幸福。是的。这会让我太开心了。我会哭的。也许他在工作时仍然让人讨厌，但他就像最好的爸爸。最好的爸爸。我想现在我自己有了孩子，这种感触更深了。是的。
And him and Holly are just happy.
Yeah.
It would make me so happy.
I would cry.
And maybe he still annoys people at work, but he's like the best dad.
The best dad.
And I think it hit me even harder now that I have kids.
Yeah.
因为我深知孩子们为你的生活带来了什么。这一集由常驻天才格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧。导演是，你知道吗，保罗·费格？哦，保罗·费格。嗯，你知道，我本来要猜肯·夸帕斯或保罗·费格，因为在早期，这是个很好的猜测。是的，而且他们，我们把许多重要的大事件集数交给了他们。在他参演期间，我给你提供一些关于保罗·费格的快讯。他执导了《办公室》的14集，但他还担任过一整季的顾问制片人。
Because I just know what kids bring to your life.
The episode was written by Resident Genius Greg Daniels.
It was directed by, do you know, Paul Feig?
Oh, Paul Feig.
Well, you know, I was going to guess Ken Quapas or Paul Feig, because they're, in the early years, that's a good guess.
Yeah, and they also, we gave them a lot of the big, like, milestone episodes.
During his time on the show, I'm going to give you some fast facts about Paul Feig.
He directed 14 episodes of the office, but he also spent an entire season where he was a consulting producer.
没错。他在片场呆了每一天。当他离开时，我说，不，保罗，别走。我在他身边感到非常有安全感。那真是一场梦。我还认为，他和他的妻子洛瑞一起，在家里举办了剧组观看派对次数最多的人。是的，他们的家太漂亮了。漂亮。
That's right.
And he was there every day on set.
When he left, I was like, no, Paul, don't.
I felt so safe with him there.
It was a dream.
He also, I think, hosted the most cast-viewing parties of anyone in his home with his incredible wife, Lori.
Yes, and their home was beautiful.
Beautiful.
而且它是如此温馨迷人。我很喜欢。他们在厨房里摆了一些像小零食一样的零食，然后我们大家拿上东西，一起去看节目。我们经常这样做。经常。保罗就像，举办了这么多的观看派对。保罗和洛瑞真的是太棒的派对主人了。
And it's just so warm and inviting.
I loved it.
They put out a little like snackity snack.
snack in the kitchen and then we would all get our stuff and we would go watch the show together.
We did that so much.
So much.
And Paul like, so many viewing parties.
Paul and Lori are just such great party hosts.
保罗是你这辈子能遇到的最会穿衣服的人之一。全套西装打领带。我从来没见他穿过便装。他的Instagram上全都是他穿着西装拿着鸡尾酒的照片。你必须去看看，因为非常有趣。非常震撼。我们即将深入了解你在Instagram上的动态。别被吓坏了。另外，保罗是保罗·费格。
Paul is the one of the best dressed people you will ever meet in your life.
Full suit with tie.
I've never not seen him in a suit.
And his Instagram is all of him in suits with cocktails.
You have to see it because it's very enjoyable.
It's very impressive.
We're about to deep dive on your feet on Instagram.
Don't get freaked out.
我应该说他是保罗·费格。哦，是的。因为很多人会想，哪个保罗？保罗·费格。保罗·费格，是的。
Also, did you talk about what the crew would do on front?
Friday when it was Paul Feig's episode.
They would all wear a tie.
Oh, yes.
Yeah, it would be Paul Feig Day, suit day, every Friday when Paul Feig directed.
And all the crew members, the camera guys, they would all wear ties.
Halloween did not end with our Halloween episodes.
In order to edit the episodes in time to air during the actual week of Halloween, we filmed
另外，你们是不是聊过剧组在周五会怎么做？周五是保罗·菲格（Paul Feig）执导的那集。大家都会系领带。哦，对。是的，保罗·菲格执导的每个周五都会变成“保罗·菲格日”、“西装日”。所有剧组人员、摄影师，都会系领带。万圣节并没有随着我们的万圣节剧集而结束。为了赶在万圣节当周剪辑好剧集，我们通常在8月份，也就是提前好几个月就开始拍摄万圣节剧集了。
our Halloween episodes like usually in August, like months before.
So every year we got two Halloween celebrations.
First was the week that we shot the Halloween episode, but then there was actual
Halloween, and during actual Halloween week, our crew would all dress up and we would have a
costume parade at lunch.
And the crew went all out.
Yeah.
We would shoot a whole day with them all in costumes and us dressed as our characters.
所以我们每年能庆祝两次万圣节。第一次是我们拍摄万圣节剧集的那个星期，但后来还有真正的万圣节，而在真正的万圣节当周，我们的剧组会全部盛装打扮，我们还会在午餐时举行化装游行。剧组成员们都全力以赴。是的。我们和他们穿着戏服拍了一整天，我们自己也打扮成了角色的样子。
One year, I don't know if you remember this, the wardrobe department dressed as the characters
from our show.
And I have pictures.
Oh.
That is hilarious.
Although this guy was a props guy.
He wasn't wardrobe.
But wardrobe dressed as us.
有一年，我不知道你记不记得，服装部门打扮成了我们剧中的角色。我还有照片。哦。太搞笑了。尽管这家伙是个道具师。他不是服装部的。但服装部把我们打扮了起来。
Oh, my gosh.
That's amazing.
I know.
It's pretty great.
Because I think something that people say a lot, but was very true for us, and maybe it's true for them, too.
We were. We were. Not just the cast. It was the crew. Yes. We looked out for one another. We enjoyed being together.
Our work days were long, but they were not as long as a typical television show. No. We averaged about 12 hours a day, and it usually was something like 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. It was rare to go as late as 7.30, but it did happen occasionally.
Yeah. But it never happened on Halloween.
哦，天哪。太棒了。我知道。真的很棒。因为我觉得大家经常说的一句话，对我们来说非常真实，也许对他们来说也是如此。我们是一个团队。我们真的是。不仅仅是演员。还有剧组人员。是的。我们互相照顾。我们很享受在一起的时光。我们的工作时间很长，但没有典型电视剧那么长。没有。我们平均每天工作12小时左右，通常是早上6点到晚上6点。很少工作到晚上7点半那么晚，但偶尔也会发生。是的。但在万圣节那天从没发生过。
We were always wrapped early.
Always.
And I think it's because so many of our crew members had families with young kids and the producers
wanted to make sure that everyone was home in time to celebrate with their families.
That's right.
And you know, Greg himself is a very big family man.
I think that those things are important.
They were important to him.
我们总是很早就收工。总是这样。我想这是因为我们很多剧组人员都有年幼的孩子，制片人们希望确保每个人都能及时回家和家人一起庆祝。没错。而且你知道，格雷格本人非常重视家庭。我认为这些事情很重要。这些对他来说很重要。
And I think when you're on a show where your showrunner, creator, has a family,
they just go into it thinking about people's families.
I always felt that way.
I felt like they knew when I went to them when I had Isabel and I was going to be bringing her to set.
I felt like I could go and have a conversation and they would help make it work.
I know that it was very important to Steve that he'd be home for dinner with his family every night.
Yes.
He would come in first thing in the morning, 5.36 a.m.
而且我认为，当你在一个剧集里，你的制片人兼创作者有家庭时，他们在接手时就会考虑到员工的家庭。我一直都有这种感觉。我觉得他们懂我，当我有了伊莎贝尔（Isabel）并打算带她去片场时，我觉得我可以去跟他们谈谈，他们会帮忙让这行得通。我知道对史蒂夫（Steve）来说非常重要的一点是，他每晚都要回家和家人吃晚饭。是的。他早上第一件事就是来，早上5点36分。
So that he could be finished by 5.30 at night.
And then some of the people who didn't have kids would stay later and then work to that 6.6.30 time frame happily, you know, for him.
him. In fact, there were a lot of younger people who preferred coming in at 8 a.m.
and working later. He did not want to come in at 5 p. But once you have kids, you're awake anyway.
You don't want to miss bedtime. You don't want to miss that different bedtime. And it can be made to
work if the people who are in charge make it work. And it happened on Halloween. Also, every year,
Matt Sone, who was one of our camera operators, and then later he became our director of photography
and even directed some episodes.
这样他晚上5点半就能完工。然后一些没有孩子的员工会留得晚一点，为了他，高高兴兴地工作到晚上6点、6点半左右，你知道的。事实上，有很多年轻人更喜欢早上8点来然后工作到很晚。他不想下午5点才来。但一旦你有了孩子，反正你也是醒着的。你不想错过哄睡。你不想错过那个不同的睡前时光。如果负责人能让它行得通，那是可以做到的。万圣节那天就是这样。此外，每年马特·索恩（Matt Sone）——他是我们的摄影师之一，后来成为了我们的摄影指导，甚至还导演过几集。
He would throw a party at his house after work for everyone in their families.
And he lived in this great neighborhood for trick-or-treating.
And we'd show up and he would have these little tables that had crafts for the kids.
Oh, he had, it was so cute.
They're like front room of their house, had little low tables with little chairs.
Yes.
It was like Kid Paradise over there.
Little stickers, projects.
他下班后会在家里为每个人及其家人举办派对。他住在一个非常适合要糖（trick-or-treating）的社区里。我们去了之后，他会准备一些小桌子，上面有给孩子们的工艺品。哦，他准备的，太可爱了。就像他们家的前厅，有低矮的小桌子和配套的小椅子。是的。简直就是那里的儿童乐园。小贴纸、手工艺项目。
You could make a little pumpkin.
Uh-huh.
And then food.
They'd order pizza.
And then we'd just go out and canvas the neighborhood.
And even cast members without kids would come.
I know BJ Novak used to go over and hand out candy.
Yeah.
你可以做一个小南瓜。嗯哼。然后是食物。他们会订披萨。然后我们就出去在社区里扫街。甚至连没有孩子的演员也会去。我知道B·J·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）以前经常去发糖。是的。
Because someone had to man the door, right?
Like if everybody leaves, someone has to be their hand out of the candy.
And BJ was like, I'll do it.
I'll never forget one of the years we went, Isabel was Tinkerbell.
And she was so excited when she rang the door that people gave her candy.
She couldn't believe it.
She was like, what is happening?
But it was really sweet that we all did that.
因为总得有人守门，对吧？如果所有人都走了，总得有人留在那儿发糖。B·J就说，我来。我永远不会忘记我们去的那一年，伊莎贝尔打扮成奇妙仙子（Tinkerbell）。她按门铃时看到人们给她糖果，兴奋极了。她简直不敢相信。她当时的表情就像是，这是怎么回事？但我们大家一起做这件事真的很温馨。
Even though we spent all day working together, we still shared these occasions with one another.
It was really sweet.
I had this like a professor in college. I'm going to get really nerdy for a second. And he was my creative writing professor. And he used to say, you know, what's what's a pleasure to do is a pleasure to experience. So if you're writing and you're and you love what you're writing, I'm going to love reading it. And I felt that way about the office. We so loved what we were doing that I think it comes through. I think we cared a lot for each other. We were very invested in each other's lives. And I think now,
the show still resonates because when you watch that, you feel it.
We were genuinely connected.
Yeah, and we still are.
We still are.
You and I hikes this morning.
尽管我们整天都在一起工作，但我们依然与彼此分享这些时刻。真的很温馨。我大学里有这样一位教授。我要稍微学术一点了。他曾是我的创意写作教授。他过去常说，你知道的，做起来开心，体验起来也就开心。所以如果你在写作，而且你热爱你所写的内容，我就会喜欢读它。我对《办公室》也是这种感觉。我们如此热爱我们所做的事情，我想这种情感能传递出来。我觉得我们非常关心彼此。我们都深深投入到彼此的生活中。我想现在这部剧仍然能引起共鸣，是因为当你观看时，你能感受到这一点。我们有着真挚的联系。是的，我们现在依然如此。我们依然如此。你和我今天早上还去远足了。
Brian Baumgartner texted me this morning.
Rayne Wilson texts me constantly.
I know.
Rain, you know, what's great is rain will text you out of nowhere and just be like,
hey, mankie.
And I'm like, hey.
He'll just text you out of nowhere.
I love you.
布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）今天早上给我发了短信。雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）经常给我发短信。我知道。雷恩，你知道最棒的是什么，雷恩会莫名其妙地给你发短信，然后就说，嘿，小伙子。而我就回，嘿。他就会莫名其妙地发短信来。我爱你。
It's so true.
Like, I feel like if Rain listened to this, he would probably text us and be like,
I am not surprised the two of you have just, you can just, you can just
talk about anything.
Yammering on and on and on.
Because of how we were on the office, and the office was my first job, it created an expectation
in me that my future job experiences would be similar.
I thought that if I got a job and I went to the producers and I said, I want this time off
真的。就像我觉得如果雷恩听了这个，他可能会给我们发短信说，你们俩能这样，我一点也不奇怪，你们随时随地都可以聊个不停。喋喋不休，没完没了。因为我们在《办公室》时的经历，而《办公室》是我的第一份工作，它在我心中种下了一种期望，即我未来的工作经历也会是类似的。我以为如果我找到了一份工作，然后我去找制片人说，我想要这段时间休假
to go to my kids' open house or I need to be finished early because this is.
is like my dad's 70th birthday or whatever it is, that they would be like, oh, yes, of course.
We can manipulate the schedule to make that time for you.
But guess what?
As it turns out, it does not like that.
It does not work that way.
We had a very special thing on the office.
And the way that this hit me, the year that I was working on my new show, splitting up together,
去参加孩子们的家长开放日，或者我需要早点收工，因为这就像是我爸爸的70岁生日或者别的什么，他们就会说，哦，是的，当然。我们可以调整日程来为你腾出时间。但你猜怎么着？事实证明，根本不是这样的。事情不是那样运作的。我们在《办公室》拥有非常特殊的经历。这件事对我的触动，是在我拍摄新剧《分分合合》（Splitting Up Together）的第一年，
and it was the first season.
And when you do the first season of show, people are especially hyper about everything because
every week they might pull the plug.
and I had asked them at the beginning of the season,
I said, I just need to be finished by five o'clock on Halloween
so that I can go trick-or-treating with my little kids.
So Halloween was on a Tuesday that year.
The Friday before, the producers came to me and said,
而且那是第一季。当你制作一部剧的第一季时，人们对每件事都高度敏感，因为他们随时可能在每周腰斩这部剧。我在季初的时候问过他们，我说，我只需要在万圣节当天下午五点前收工，这样我就可以和我的小孩子们去要糖了。所以那一年的万圣节是星期二。前一个星期五，制片人们来找我说，
Jenna, we've run late this week,
and we had to drop a couple of scenes.
And the only day that we can rent this crane
in order to get this shot that we missed this week is on Halloween.
And we're going to need to tack it on to the end of the day,
so I'm very sorry.
We'll still get you out by 7.30, 8 o'clock.
First of all, you have to understand,
珍娜（Jenna），我们这周进度落后了，我们不得不删掉几个场景。而我们唯一能租到吊车来补拍这周漏掉镜头的日子就是在万圣节当天。我们得把它加到那天收工之后，所以非常抱歉。我们还是会让你在7点半、8点左右收工。首先，你得明白，
Jenna's children are young.
They're not trigger-treating at 8 o'clock.
No, I said,
I said, guys, Halloween's over by 8 o'clock.
It's over.
You know, we're sleeping at 8.
Yeah.
They're in the early window.
珍娜的孩子还小。他们可不在8点钟去要糖。不，我说，我说，各位，万圣节8点钟就结束了。结束了。你知道的，我们8点钟都要睡觉了。是的。他们要在较早的时间段。
Yeah. It's still a little light out.
Yeah.
It's still a little daylight out at that age.
And then on Sunday morning, you call me up.
Now I'm going to start crying.
You called me up and you said,
what are you doing tonight?
at 5 o'clock. And I said nothing. And you said, I know what you're doing. You're coming,
对。天还亮着一点。是的。那个年纪的时候，天还没完全黑。然后星期天早上，你打电话给我。现在我要开始哭了。你打电话给我说，你今晚5点钟有什么安排？我说没有。然后你说，我知道你要做什么。你要过来，
dress up your kids. Come over to my house. I've talked to six of my neighbors and they're going
going to hand out candy to your kids. I'll get my kids dressed up and we're going trick-or-treating.
You will not miss Halloween on my watch. You will not miss it. I started sobbing.
Sobbing now. We're both tearing up now. We're both tearing up. And we did just that.
I got to dress up my kids in their Halloween costumes.
You dress up your kids in not their Halloween costumes, but in costume.
We, right, because you didn't want to.
Our kids still have two huge dress-up vins because they love to play dress-up.
给你的孩子们换上戏服。来我家。我已经跟六个邻居说好了，他们会给你的孩子们发糖。我会把我的孩子打扮好，然后我们去要糖。在我的监督下，你绝对不会错过万圣节。你绝对不会错过的。我开始号啕大哭。现在又哭起来了。我们俩现在眼眶都湿润了。我们俩都眼眶湿润了。我们真的就这么做了。我给我的孩子们换上了万圣节戏服。你给你的孩子们换上的不是万圣节戏服，但也算是盛装打扮。我们，没错，因为你不想。我们的孩子至今还有两个巨大的变装收纳箱，因为他们喜欢玩变装游戏。
They still do.
And I told the kids what was going to happen.
And my kids were like, Weston and Harper cannot miss Halloween with their mom.
They cannot miss Halloween.
I said, I know, guys.
So we're going to make Halloween happen for them.
And they were so excited.
And their one thing was, well, we don't.
他们现在还这么做。我把将要发生的事情告诉了孩子们，我的孩子们说，韦斯顿（Weston）和哈珀（Harper）绝对不能错过和妈妈一起过万圣节。他们绝对不能错过。我说，我知道，孩子们。所以我们要为他们把万圣节变成现实。他们兴奋极了。他们唯一的要求是，嗯，我们不想...
don't want to mess up our actual costumes.
Yeah.
Because they still had their...
They wanted to wait for Halloween to put on their costume.
They had their parade at school coming up and all that.
And I said, why don't we all pick out a costume from the dress-up bin and we'll all
dress up to trick or treat?
And they were so excited.
弄坏我们真正的戏服。对。因为他们还留着他们的……他们想等到万圣节那天再穿上戏服。他们学校接下来还有化装游行之类的活动。我说，为什么我们不从变装箱里选一套戏服，然后我们全都盛装打扮去要糖呢？他们兴奋极了。
And they all dressed up.
Now, here's a question that I have for you, which I've always wondered.
Did your neighbors have candy or did you go to their houses and give them candy to give me?
Okay, so I live in a very cute neighborhood.
It's like white picket fences.
It's very cute.
You know all your neighbors.
I know all my neighbors.
他们全都打扮好了。现在，我有一个问题想问你，我一直很好奇。你的邻居们家里有糖，还是你去了他们家，然后把糖拿给他们让他们发给我？好吧，我住在一个非常可爱的社区里。就像有白色栅栏的那种。非常可爱。你认识所有的邻居。我认识所有的邻居。
You guys do like block parties and stuff.
We do like summertime, Fourth of July.
Oh, we do some of them for the July.
Yeah, we do barbecues and we have a, oh gosh, what's it called?
Batchie ball tournament.
And we just always are hanging out.
So I knew who I could go to on my street and they all have children.
And they all know what this means.
你们会搞街区派对之类的活动。我们会在夏天搞，比如独立日。哦，我们会为独立日搞一些活动。是的，我们会搞烧烤，我们还有个，哦天哪，那叫什么来着？地掷球锦标赛。我们总是聚在一起。所以我知道我可以去找我这条街上的谁，他们都有孩子。他们都懂这意味着什么。
go trick-or-treating with your kids when they're little. I went to them and I said,
here's the deal. My best friend is going to have to work Halloween and she's not going to be
able to be with her kids on Halloween and they're little and she won't be able to take them
trick-or-treating and I'm going to have them come over here and it would just mean so much to me.
I said, I will bring you candy and all of them were like, we are so happy to help.
You don't even need to bring this candy. We have so much candy. We want to get rid of candy.
They're like, just tell us when. And I told them I would text them when when we were coming.
because they were all saying they wanted to make sure they'd be home at that time.
带着你的小孩子们去要糖。我去找他们说，情况是这样的。我最好的朋友万圣节得上班，万圣节她不能和孩子们在一起，而且她的孩子们还小，她没法带他们去要糖，我要让他们来这里，这对我来说意义重大。我说，我会带糖给你们的，他们所有人都说，我们很乐意帮忙。你甚至不需要带糖来。我们有的是糖。我们正想把糖处理掉呢。他们说，只要告诉我们什么时候。我告诉他们等我们快到时会发短信给他们。因为他们都说想确保自己那个时间在家。
And so they all knew we were coming.
And I texted them when Jenna and her kids were on the way.
And I said, okay, we're on.
And we came over, and it was the cutest thing.
And we trick or treated.
And then we came back to your house, and we had s'mores.
Yeah.
Remember?
所以他们都知道我们要去。当珍娜和她的孩子们在路上时，我给他们发了短信。我说，好了，开始了。我们过去了，那可真可爱。我们去要糖了。然后我们回到了你家，吃了棉花糖夹饼（s'mores）。对。还记得吗？
We did s'mores in the backyard.
And it was amazing.
And it is one of the kindest things that anyone has ever done for me in my life.
And, you know, there's already so many ways as a working parent that we feel conflicted about missing things.
I am always trying to balance my personal ambition with my desire to be a very present parent.
And I give up a lot of opportunities.
And I know you do too.
There are a lot of jobs that work outside of the city and we don't even throw our hat in the ring because we don't like to leave.
我们在后院烤了棉花糖。太棒了。这是我一生中别人为我做过的最暖心的事之一。而且，你知道的，作为一个职场父母，我们常常会因为错过一些事情而感到纠结。我一直在努力平衡我的个人野心和我想要成为一个陪伴在孩子身边的父母的愿望。我放弃了很多机会。我知道你也是。有很多在市区外的工作，我们甚至都不会去尝试争取，因为我们不喜欢离开。
So anyway, thank you.
Yeah.
That was amazing.
It saved the day.
Well, I was so happy to do it, Jenna.
I just love you.
And I just know what it means.
And I know as a working parent, we all have to make sacrifices that are really hard.
总之，谢谢你。是的。那太棒了。真是解了围。哦，我很高兴能这么做，珍娜。我只是很爱你。我懂这意味着什么。我知道作为一个职场父母，我们都得作出非常艰难的牺牲。
I'm a working parent, and I'm also a parent who has a child that has to navigate joint custody.
And it hits a real nerve with me because there are some moments that I miss out on because of joint custody,
even though my joint custody is exceptionally great, really.
Like we get a long grate, we work well together.
I'm on very good terms with her dad and her stepmom, and we really work together to make it all happen.
But there are still moments that you miss.
For example, some years you trade off Christmas Day, and that's really hard, even though you're going to see her the next day to make it fair to both houses.
And so what we have stated in our family is it doesn't matter what date it is.
我是一个职场父母，同时我也是一个需要处理共同抚养孩子问题的父母。这真的触动了我的痛处，因为有些时刻我错过了，就是因为共同抚养，尽管我的共同抚养情况其实非常好，真的。比如我们相处得很融洽，合作得很愉快。我和她爸爸以及她继母的关系非常好，我们真的齐心协力让一切顺利进行。但仍然会有你错过的时刻。例如，有些年份你们轮流过圣诞节，这真的很艰难，尽管为了两边公平，你第二天就会见到她。所以我们在家里达成的一点是：日期是什么并不重要。
It matters that you celebrate together as a family.
that's what I thought. I was like, you know what, that TV show might get to take quote unquote
Halloween from you, the date, but they don't get to take the experience away from you.
And you know what, Angela, when I was on set, I said to them, the thing is, I can't make Halloween
happen on any other day. It's not like Thanksgiving or Christmas or these other holidays, even
your birthday, where you're like, oh, I'm sorry, I can't come in for thanks. I've had many
Thanksgiving a week late. The family couldn't be sure.
unit until later. Right. And you make your own Thanksgiving and you make your own holidays. You open
重要的是作为一家人在一起庆祝。我也是这么想的。我就想，你知道吗，那个电视节目或许可以从你那里拿走所谓的万圣节，拿走那个日期，但他们拿不走属于你的体验。你知道吗，安吉拉，当我在片场时，我对他们说，问题是，我无法在任何其他日子让万圣节发生。它不像感恩节、圣诞节或其他这些节日，甚至不像你的生日，你可以说，哦，很抱歉，我感恩节赶不回来。我的感恩节晚了一周过很多次。家人们无法确定。直到后来才聚在一起。对的。你可以自己过感恩节，你可以自己创造节日。你可以拆
gifts three days after Christmas, but it's your Christmas. I said, I can't make a neighborhood
hand out candy. Yes, you can, Jenna. Angela Kinsey can. Well, I was happy that we could do that.
And I would do it again. I'd go bug all my neighbors. I know you would. I know you would. But created a
really special memory for the family. Yeah, that was our Halloween. BFF, Air High Five.
Air high five, boom.
And what are your thoughts after listening to that again?
Well, first of all, I want to bring back the birthday hike tradition.
Okay.
圣诞节三天后的礼物，但那是你的圣诞节。我说，我没法让一个社区的人出来发糖。对，你可以，珍娜。安吉拉·金西就可以。好吧，我很高兴我们能做到。而且我愿意再做一次。我要去烦我所有的邻居。我知道你会的。我知道你会的。但这为这个家庭创造了一个非常特别的回忆。是的，那是我们的万圣节。闺蜜，击个掌。空中击掌，砰。再次听到这些，你有什么感想？嗯，首先，我想把生日徒步的传统带回来。好吧。
We did that for a few years and then instead we would like meet and have lunch or something.
I want to do the birthday hike again.
Birthday hike again.
And I want you to wear that hat you wore that was a birthday cake.
I found that.
No way.
Yes.
Okay.
我们那样做了几年，后来我们改成见面吃个午饭什么的。我想再次进行生日徒步。再次生日徒步。我还想让你戴上那个做成生日蛋糕样式的帽子。我找到了。真的吗？是的。好的。
Save it.
We're going to go for a hike on my birthday and I will wear it.
I will bring it.
Done.
And then just listening to us, lady, what was so wild to me was the seeds of so many things.
One, you in your brain just was like, oh, here's a fast fact.
Little did you know that you could be locked into those for years.
And also your thoughts are so organized.
留着它。我生日那天我们要去徒步，我会戴着它。我会把它带上。说定了。然后听着我们说话，天哪，最让我惊叹的是许多事情的萌芽。第一，你脑子里就觉得，哦，这里有个冷知识。你当时根本不知道你可能会被这些死死套牢好几年。还有你的思绪是如此有条理。
You know, you had this like multiple printed out document.
I remember I had a stack of note cards in front of me that I had jotted a bunch of things down on that I spread out over this coffee.
table. And I also had all these pictures from Halloween that I spread out in front of us that we could
look at. I had my script from Halloween. But, you know, we come at things from these different
perspectives. And I love that neither of us knew what we were going to share exactly. And that's just
something I love about our friendship is just how we hold so much of what matters to us is the same
at our core, you know? Like our values. Our values. Our moral compass. Our love for our love for
our families. But, you know, you and I can take a walk down the street right now. And what you would
你知道，你有一份打印出来的多页文档。我记得我面前有一叠便签纸，上面潦草地记了很多事情，我把它们铺在这张咖啡桌上。我面前还铺着所有万圣节的照片，供我们查看。我有我的万圣节剧本。但是，你知道的，我们是从不同的视角来看待事情的。我喜欢我们俩都不知道对方到底要分享什么。这就是我喜欢我们友谊的一点，那就是我们核心价值观中有那么多对我们很重要的东西是不谋而合的，你知道吗？就像我们的价值观。我们的价值观。我们的道德罗盘。我们对家人的爱。但是，你知道，你和我现在可以去街上走走。而你所
see and share about and what I would see and share about would be completely different. And yours is
always fascinating to me. Yeah. And entertaining and interesting. Like, I love how your brain works.
And I just felt like I was reliving all of that. And it's such a fun conversation between two friends
about a magical time in our life. And I'm just so thankful that we get to continue.
you talking and sharing all these years later, you know?
Mm-hmm.
I mean, this has been a real gift to my life.
Yes, same.
看到并分享的，和我所看到并分享的将完全不同。而你的总是让我觉得很着迷。是的。而且充满娱乐性和趣味性。就像，我喜欢你的大脑运转的方式。我感觉自己就像在重温这一切。这真是一场两个朋友之间关于我们生活中神奇时光的有趣对话。我很感激多年后的今天我们还能继续聊天和分享，你知道吗？嗯。我是说，这对我的人生来说真的是一份礼物。是的，我也是。
Yeah.
What about you?
What about you hearing us in my garage?
Well, my first thought was that it's very hilarious to me that you were eating.
I'm sorry.
And I felt like I was talking really fast, really fast.
It's funny because it's kind of what you said.
I think that the things that make our partnership as podcast hosts,
是啊。你呢？听到我们在我的车库里的录音，你有什么感想？嗯，我的第一个想法是，你当时在吃东西，这让我觉得非常搞笑。对不起。我觉得我当时语速飞快，真的非常快。这很有趣，因为就像你说的。我认为正是那些造就了我们作为播客主持人的契约精神的东西，
works so well, it's evident in that very first recording. I also know why you were talking fast.
Why? Lady, don't you remember? No. Okay. So was I in a hurry? No, but it was your birthday.
So we went for this hike. Uh-huh. And then we came back and I was hungry, so we stopped to get
something for me to eat. And then we had pickup that day, but our kids were younger and they got out
earlier. Oh. Is that right? So we were, we did have a deadline. We had a time deadline.
bit of a hurry. So we weren't rushed, but we also didn't have all afternoon. Okay. Okay. And that's why you're
not, well, also, I found emails between us after we had recorded it and I was like, that was so much fun, you know, and I was like, did you make it? And you're like, yeah, I made it in plenty of time, you know, all that kind of stuff. Oh, wow. Your digital clutter is filling out the picture for us once again.
You're welcome. Oh, well, we've come a long way, seven years, 500 million downloads.
配合得那么默契，从那第一次录音中就能明显看出来。我也知道你为什么语速快。为什么？天哪，你不记得了吗？没有。好吧。那我当时是在赶时间吗？不是，但那是你的生日。所以我们去进行了一次徒步。嗯哼。然后我们回来了，我很饿，所以我们顺便去买点吃的。然后那天我们有接送任务，但我们的孩子比较小，他们放学较早。哦。是这样吗？所以我们当时确实有截止时间。我们有一个时间上的截止线。有点赶时间。所以我们倒不是说有多匆忙，但我们也没有整个下午的时间。好吧。好吧。这就是为什么你没有……哦，对了，我还找到了我们录完音后彼此发的电子邮件，当时我就想，那真的太有趣了，你知道的，然后我就问，你赶上了吗？然后你说，嗯，我赶上了，时间很充裕，你知道的，诸如此类的话。哦，哇。你的数字杂物又一次为我们拼凑出了当时的画面。不客气。哦，好吧，我们已经走了很长的一路，七年，五亿次下载。
And it all started with that one recording in your garage. Just amazing.
And all of it happened because of you guys listening.
Thank you so much. And it's also due to a really great team of people currently and throughout the years.
And we actually thought that for our Around the Town segment, in honor of this milestone, it would be kind of fun to catch up with our office ladies family and see what they have been up to.
So let's kick things off with a little message from someone who's been with us from the very beginning, Colin Anderson.
Hi, ladies. This is Colin Anderson. I was the exec who signed Office Ladies to a Wolf back in the day.
One of my favorite things about the Office Ladies launch, which was October 2019, was that our company, the marketing team strategy,
a shout out to Bill Irwin, forecast the show to get 400,000 downloads a month. And we hit over a million
这一切都始于你在车库里的那次录音。真是太神奇了。这一切的发生都归功于你们大家的收听。非常感谢。这也归功于现在和多年来一直非常优秀的团队。实际上我们想，为了我们的“走过小镇”环节，为了纪念这个里程碑，回顾一下“办公室女士”的家人们最近都在忙些什么，应该会挺有趣的。所以让我们以一个一直陪伴我们走到今天的人的一段简短留言来拉开序幕吧，科林·安德森。嗨，女士们。我是科林·安德森。我就是当年签下“办公室女士”加入Earwolf的那个高管。关于“办公室女士”2019年10月开播，我最喜欢的事情之一就是我们公司，营销团队的策略——向比尔·欧文致敬——预测这个节目每个月能获得40万次下载量。而我们在
in the first week. Absolutely crazy numbers, more than double any of the other shows we had on
the network at the time. And 200,000 of those listeners told us that Office Ladies was the first
podcast they'd ever listened to. I wonder how many new listeners you brought us into podcasting since then.
So I guess the personal tip bit that Office Ladies listeners might know about me is that I had a kidney
stone last year. That seemed to go away. I had an ultrasound. They said, no, no kidney stones. You must have
past it. And then a couple of weeks later, I was in a lot of pain, ended up in urgent care
and had to have an emergency operation to remove my kidney stone. It was painful and dignified
a lot for a gentleman to go through. And listening to office ladies a couple of weeks ago
第一周就突破了一百万次。绝对疯狂的数据，是我们当时网络上任何其他节目的两倍多。其中有20万听众告诉我们，“办公室女士”是他们听过的第一个播客。我不知道自那以后你们为播客行业带来了多少新听众。所以我想，“办公室女士”的听众们可能知道的关于我的一个私人小八卦是，我去年长了结石。它好像自己消下去了。我做了超声波检查。他们说，没有了，没有肾结石了。你一定已经把它排出来了。然后几周后，我感到剧烈疼痛，最后去了急诊中心，不得不做紧急手术来取出肾结石。对于一个绅士来说，这既痛苦又有损尊严。几周前听“办公室女士”
and hearing that Billy Elish has listened to every episode, I'm like, oh great, now Billy Eilish
knows about my kidney stone. I set up my own podcast business about a year ago. And
And Office Ladies were one of my first clients.
So since then, I've been helping build the Office Ladies' Network with Lazy Genius.
And we brought in how we made your mother last year.
So please go and listen to both of those shows once you've finished this episode.
And the three of us just got talking a few weeks ago about a new Office Ladies' idea that I'm hoping listeners get to hear at some point this year.
Congratulations, Jenna and Angela on this brilliant show and the community that you've built.
听到比利·艾利什听了每一集节目，我就想，哦太好了，现在比利·艾利什也知道我的肾结石了。我大约在一年前创立了自己的播客业务。而且“办公室女士”是我的第一批客户之一。所以从那以后，我一直在和“灵机一动”一起帮助建立“办公室女士”的网络。我们去年还引进了“你是怎么认识你妈妈的”。所以请大家在这集节目结束后去听听这两档节目。我们三个人在几周前刚刚聊起了一个新的“办公室女士”创意，我希望听众们今年能在某个时候听到它。恭喜珍娜和安吉拉制作了这档精彩的节目以及你们建立的社区。
congrats on 500 million downloads.
Everything about that was perfection.
I also love people hearing just the joy that is Colin Anderson.
I loved all of that.
I love that we got the update on his kidney stone journey.
And yeah, Colin was part of the team that signed us to Earwolf.
Yes.
And then our very first producer, who we worked with at Earwolf,
恭喜下载量达到5亿次。这一切简直完美无缺。我也喜欢人们听到科林·安德森身上那种纯粹的快乐。我太喜欢这一切了。我很高兴能听到他关于肾结石之旅的最新进展。是的，科林是当年签下我们加入Earwolf的团队成员之一。是的。然后是我们最早的制作人，我们在Earwolf共事过，
and then when we moved to Sirius XM was Cody Fisher, no relation.
and here's what she's been up to.
Hi, Jenna. Hi, Angela.
Hi, Office Ladies, listeners. It's me, Cody.
First, I just want to say, Jen and Angela, congratulations on 500 million downloads.
I'm so impressed. It's so cool, but I'm also not surprised. The show rules.
What have I been up to since my time on Office Ladies?
Well, I'm still making podcasts. I'm at Sirius XM.
后来当我们跳槽到Sirius XM时，她是科迪·费舍尔，没有亲戚关系。以下是她最近的动态。嗨，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。嗨，“办公室女士”的听众们。我是科迪。首先，我只想说，珍娜和安吉拉，恭喜你们获得5亿次下载量。我太佩服了。这太酷了，但我也不感到意外。这个节目太棒了。自从离开“办公室女士”后我在忙什么？嗯，我还在做播客。我在Sirius XM工作。
I have taken up five billion hobbies that I've given up on,
but I managed to rewire two antique lamps without burning my house down.
Very proud of that.
I'm also still worrying about the sound quality of this voice memo
and what Sam will have to do to clean it up.
Sam, I'm trying my best.
I'm in my closet.
I've re-recorded this four times because I heard noise in the background.
我培养了五十亿个已经放弃了的爱好，但我成功重修了两盏古董台灯而没有把我的房子烧掉。我为此感到非常自豪。我也依然在担心这段语音备忘录的音质，以及山姆为了清理它必须做些什么。山姆，我在尽力了。我在我的衣橱里。这段录音我已经重录了四次，因为我听到了背景噪音。
I hope this is good.
Bye, everyone.
Oh, Cody, thank you.
That sounded great, Cody.
It did.
I also think I know who I should hit up with all my extra lamps.
I was thinking that immediately.
Okay, this is really good information.
希望这个效果不错。再见，大家。哦，科迪，谢谢你。听起来真棒，科迪。确实如此。我也觉得我知道该把所有多余的台灯拿去给谁了。我当时立刻就这么想了。好吧，这真的是很有用的信息。
Also, Cody's cat and my cat look like their siblings.
She has a tuxedo cat, who I love.
Okay, and now we're going to hear from Ainsley Bubbaco, everyone.
Get it right.
Who I've known pre-office ladies.
She's going to explain a little bit about that and tell you all what she's up to.
Hello, office ladies, it is Ainsley.
Congratulations on 500 million downloads.
还有，科迪的猫和我的猫长得像亲兄弟姐妹一样。她有一只我超爱的燕尾服猫。好的，接下来我们要听听艾因斯利·巴巴科的声音，各位。别念错了。我和她在“办公室女士”之前就认识了。她会稍微解释一下这段渊源，并告诉大家她最近在忙什么。哈喽，“办公室女士”，我是艾因斯利。恭喜你们获得5亿次下载量。
I honestly can't even wrap my brain around that number, but I will say it is well-deserved.
I know how much time and love goes into each episode and how much you care about the fans.
So it's only fitting that you've hit this huge milestone.
My time on the Office Ladies team started just as me helping Jenna during the pandemic while she was homeschooling her kids.
and turned into a five-plus year job that brought me wonderful new friends into my life.
So I'm very grateful to have been a part of it.
I'd actually never seen the office before I started working on the podcast.
And it's funny.
老实说，我的大脑甚至无法理解这个数字，但我必须说这是实至名归的。我知道每一集节目倾注了多少时间和爱，以及你们有多在乎粉丝。所以你们能达到这个巨大的里程碑是再合适不过了。我在“办公室女士”团队的时光始于大流行期间帮助珍娜，当时她在家里给孩子们上学。后来演变成了一份长达五年多的工作，为我的生活带来了非常棒的新朋友。所以我非常感激能成为其中的一员。其实在开始制作这个播客之前，我从来没看过《办公室》。这很有趣。
I see why people love it.
What am I doing now?
I am currently performing in a musical, which Angela and Jenna came to see me in this past weekend.
and next week I'm traveling to Paris with some friends,
and hopefully by the time this airs, I'll be doing something else.
Fabulous.
Thank you for checking in, and cheers to the next 500 million downloads.
Lots of love.
我明白了为什么人们会喜欢它。我现在在做什么？我目前正在参演一部音乐剧，安吉拉和珍娜上周末来看我演出了。下周我要和一些朋友去巴黎旅行，希望在这个节目播出的时候，我已经去忙别的了。太棒了。谢谢你们的问候，为下一个5亿次下载干杯。爱你们。
I like, she was like, it's funny.
It's pretty good.
Guys, Ainsley is a phenomenal actress.
She's a superstar.
Yeah, and she can sing.
Oh, her voice is amazing.
She was terrific in this musical.
我喜欢她那种语气，她当时说，这很有趣。挺不错的。挺不错的。伙计们，艾因斯利是一位杰出的演员。她是个超级巨星。是的，而且她会唱歌。哦，她的嗓音太棒了。她在音乐剧里的表现好极了。
Really great.
It might be going to go into New York, so we're going to have to have her let us know.
Yeah.
We'll shout it out.
And we also reached out to Cassie, you know, huge part of office ladies.
She is actually traveling internationally right now.
And Cassie and I have been trading messages and she said,
真的很棒。它可能会去纽约上演，所以我们要让她通知我们一声。是的。我们会大声宣传的。我们会大声宣传的。我们还联系了卡西，你们知道的，“办公室女士”的重要成员。她目前正在进行国际旅行。卡西和我一直在发消息沟通，她说：
Angie, I owe you an email.
Apologies for the delay, but she's going to get back to us when she's done with all her travels.
And it looks like she's having an amazing time.
I am so excited that she's traveling.
And we do have a don't buy.
me when I'm traveling policy here on office ladies. So we like to give people the space to
enjoy their vacations. But yeah, Cassie, just if you're listening, thank you so much for being
such a big part of these 500 million downloads. We're so happy that you're out there living your
安吉，我欠你一封电子邮件。回复晚了请见谅，但等她所有的旅行结束後，她会给我们回信的。看起来她玩得非常开心。我很高兴她去旅行了。我们“办公室女士”这里有一个政策，那就是在旅行时不要打扰我。所以我们喜欢给人们空间去享受他们的假期。但是，是的，卡西，如果你在听的话，非常感谢你成为这5亿次下载中如此重要的一部分。我们很高兴看到你在外面过着你最好的
best life. Yeah. And when you're back, you'll have to share all about your travels. And we can't wait
to hear from you. We would accept a travel journal. Oh, yes, we would. And then I think before we go,
We need to get a little around the town from Matt and Sam.
Sam, you want to go first?
Sam, day one in the studio with us, 500 million downloads later.
I chose to answer this the same way Cody and Colin and Ainsley did as if we haven't seen each other every day.
Oh, great.
So, John and Angela, it's so good to hear from you.
生活。是的。等你回来了，你得和大家分享你所有的旅行见闻。我们已经迫不及待想听到你的消息了。我们非常欢迎旅行日记。哦，是的，我们会的。然后我想在我们结束之前，我们需要听听马特和山姆带来的“走过小镇”环节。山姆，你想先来吗？山姆，跟我们在录音室的第一天，5亿次下载之后。我选择像科迪、科林和艾因斯利那样来回答这个问题，就好像我们不是每天都见面一样。哦，太棒了。所以，珍娜和安吉拉，听到你们的声音真好。
First, I miss you both so much every day.
Second, life is good.
Life is small for me right now.
I make two to three podcasts a week, which seems wild to me that I used to make five to ten per week
for 10 years. So since I've seen you last, Earwolf was acquired by Sirius XM, which was great for
the owners of Earwolf. Pretty weak for everyone else. I made it about two years before being laid off,
which I'll admit was terrifying. But I don't know if you too remember the show I was on before I left,
the office ladies, those two absolute angels swooped in and saved me by rehiring me on the show
首先，我每天都非常非常想念你们俩。其次，生活很好。我现在的生活很平静。我一周制作两到三个播客，这对我来说简直难以置信，因为我以前十年里一周要制作五到十个。自从我上次见到你们以来，Earwolf被Sirius XM收购了，这对Earwolf的所有者来说很棒。对其他人来说简直弱爆了。我坚持了大约两年就被裁员了，我承认当时吓坏了。但我不确定你们俩是否还记得我离开前参与制作的那个节目，“办公室女士”，那两个绝对的天使突然出现，重新雇用我来做我被裁掉的那个节目，
I was laid off from, which as far as I know, that's the only instance of that happening that I can think
of. I got out of that toxic relationship I was in when we met. I've recently started dating a love
woman in Canada named Stephanie. It's new to me. I'm taking it slowly, but I do love her very much.
My dog Raman is still alive. He turns nine this month. He's still very fat and very dumb and very
wonderful. I got sober about a year ago. I've been slowly rebuilding my life since then.
No complaints, though. Whatever I left behind in my old life has been repaid to me currently
10 times over. As I wrap this up, I just wanted to say how good it is to hear from you both.
You both changed my life in many ways, and I'm proud to be a part of this show still.
据我所知，这是我能想到的唯一发生过这种事的情况。我摆脱了我们相识时身处的那段有毒的关系。我最近开始和加拿大一位可爱的女性斯蒂芬妮约会。这对我来说是个新体验。我正在慢慢来，但我确实非常爱她。我的狗狗拉面还活着。它这个月就九岁了。它依然很胖、很笨，而且非常可爱。我大约在一年前戒酒了。从那以后，我一直在慢慢重塑我的生活。不过没什么好抱怨的。我在老生活中抛下的所有东西，现在都已经十倍地回报给我了。在结束之际，我只想说能听到你们俩的声音真好。你们俩在许多方面改变了我的人生，我很自豪能依然成为这个节目的一员。
I was aware from our very first taping that we had something special. I lost all my e-mails
in the last 10 years when I left Sirius XM,
but I'm genuinely pretty sure you both have emails from me around that time
telling you guys in that very fact that you guys were on to something very magical here.
I tried to do the math,
and by my rough estimate,
I've made probably 3 to 4,000 podcasts over the last decade.
I made some really magical stuff with some really truly special people,
从我们的第一次录音开始，我就意识到我们拥有了特别的东西。当我离开Sirius XM时，我失去了过去十年的所有电子邮件，但我真的非常确信，你们俩当时都收到了我发去的电子邮件，我在邮件里准确地指出，你们俩正在这里酝酿着某种非常神奇的事情。我试着算了一下，根据我粗略的估计，在过去的十年里，我大概制作了3000到4000个播客。我同一些真正非常特别的人一起制作了一些非常神奇的东西，
but it all pales in comparison to what you two have built here.
You two have built a community.
Every person that has talked to you today has used that phrase,
and podcasts end, but communities last for,
And to the people that email me saying they listen to the show while they're running marathons, having babies, getting married, I see you and I hear you.
And every email blows my mind.
Thank you, truly.
I'm always available.
但与你们在这里建立的一切相比，所有这些都黯然失色。你们俩建立了一个社区。今天跟你们聊过的每个人都用了这个词，播客会结束，但社区会永远存在。对于那些给我发邮件说他们在跑马拉松、生孩子、结婚时都在听这个节目的人，我看见了你们，我也听到了你们。每一封邮件都让我大开眼界。真的，谢谢你们。我随时都在。
Please email me at the next 500 million mark.
Aw, Sam.
Sam, can I also say your email reminded me of my journals?
Yeah, yeah.
You wrote it as if, oh, Jenna and I were sitting in the room with you.
Yeah.
We love you so much, Sam.
I love you, too.
请在下一个5亿的里程碑时给我发邮件吧。哦，山姆。山姆，我也可以说吗？你的邮件让我想起了我的日记。是啊是啊。你写得好像，哦，珍娜和我当时正和你坐在同一个房间里。是啊。我们太爱你了，山姆。我也爱你们。
I can't believe the reach.
500 million.
And congrats.
I hope you guys are genuinely so proud of what you've built.
Thank you so much.
I am really proud of it.
I really am.
And so many people that we meet now when we're out and about in the world,
我简直不敢相信这个覆盖范围。5亿。恭喜你们。我希望你们真的为自己建立的一切感到无比自豪。非常感谢。我真的为之感到自豪。真的。现在我们在现实世界中遇到的大多数人，
you know, my favorite thing is when I'll be at an airport and someone goes,
lady, and immediately that they're an office lady's listener.
Yes.
Well, listen, finally, Matt Beagle, we want to hear from you,
our newest member of the office ladies team.
We need everyone to understand how amazing.
Matt Beagle is. Matt is just the most fantastic, calming presence. No matter what we need,
when we need it, he's anticipated our need and he's taken care of it. Matt, I hope your family
你知道的，我最喜欢的事情就是当我身处机场时，有人喊一声“lady”，然后立刻就能认出他们是“办公室女士”的听众。是的。好吧，听着，最后是马特·比格尔，我们想听听你的声音，“办公室女士”团队的最新成员。我们需要让每个人都明白马特·比格尔有多么了不起。马特有着极其美妙、让人平静的气场。无论我们需要什么，什么时候需要，他都能预料到我们的需求并将其处理妥当。马特，我希望你的家人
knows what a badass you are. You're a treasure and you will do things that are just so near and dear
to my heart, which is like before every Zoom that we have, you will set out an agenda in a Google
doc, but you have links to all the other Google Docs that we might, might need to reference.
Like, maybe we will. Maybe we won't, but it's there. It's all in one document.
Here's another thing Matt will do. He knew I was taking a road trip with Josh. He knew we had
an edit coming up and that I wouldn't be able to access it in a computer, like in a Google Doc.
So he texted it to me, hey, Ange, in case you want to listen on your car ride. I was like,
that's amazing. Amazing. Well, thank you. Can I stop following Sam to?
知道你有多么厉害。你是个宝藏，你做的那些事情真的深深触动了我的心，比如在我们每次开Zoom会议之前，他都会在谷歌文档中列出一个议程，并且附上了我们可能需要参考的所有其他谷歌文档的链接。比如，也许我们会用到。也许我们用不到，但它就在那里。全都在一个文档里。马特还会做另一件事。他知道我要和乔什去公路旅行。他知道我们接下来有一个剪辑工作，而且我无法像在谷歌文档里那样在电脑上访问它。所以他把它发短信给我，“嘿，安吉，以防你想在车上听。”当时我就想，这太棒了。太棒了。谢谢。我可以不再跟着山姆发言了吗？
I'm always following Sam after he's like read some poetry or another or something.
I know.
He has such a rich history here.
Can I go first next time?
I'm kidding.
Congratulations.
This is just such a special place to be.
I feel so lucky to be part of this team and family and history.
他读完某首诗或者别的东西之后，我总是得接着他发言。我知道。他在我们这里有着如此丰富的经历。下次我能先来吗？开玩笑的。恭喜。这是一个如此特别的地方。能成为这个团队、这个大家庭和这段历史的一部分，我感到非常幸运。
And I'm just thrilled to be here.
And I'm super excited for everyone involved for this milestone.
So thank you to everyone.
Thanks, Matt.
Yeah.
We're so glad you're part of this team as well.
From day one.
我很高兴能来到这里。我为所有参与这个里程碑的人感到超级兴奋。所以谢谢大家。谢谢，马特。是的。我们也很高兴你能成为这个团队的一员。是的。从第一天开始。
We call you Command F.
We do because we were both in a Google Doc, and it was really hard to search for things.
And Matt just goes, well, do Command F.
And we were like, what?
What's Command F?
We'd never heard of it.
We'd never heard of Command F.
从第一天开始。我们叫你“Ctrl F”（查找命令）。我们确实这么叫，因为我们俩都在一个谷歌文档里，搜索东西真的很难。然后马特就说，用“Ctrl F”就行了。我们就问，什么？什么是“Ctrl F”？我们从来没听说过。我们从来没听说过“Ctrl F”。
So now that we call you our Command F, because you help us find everything and figure everything out.
And you might have a coffee mug waiting for you here that says Command F.
Might.
I know that you do.
If you know Angela, you know that's been ordered.
Well, you guys, I hope you just feel our love coming through your headphones or your car radio.
Car radio?
How do you listen to podcasts?
所以现在我们叫你我们的“Ctrl F”，因为你帮我们找到一切并搞定了一切。而且这里可能有一个咖啡杯在等着你，上面写着“Ctrl F”。可能。我知道已经订好了。好了，伙计们，我希望你们能感受到我们的爱正通过你们的耳机或汽车收音机传递给你们。汽车收音机？你们是怎么听播客的？
However you're listening to our podcasts, I hope you just feel the love that we have for you
all and what this has meant to us and it's changed our lives.
And we're so, so thankful.
And we just love you and we hope you have a great week.
Yes.
And we will be here trying to come up.
with what is the next fun thing we're going to chat about.
Yeah.
无论你们是通过什么方式听我们的播客，我希望你们都能感受到我们对你们所有人的爱，以及这一切对我们的意义，它改变了我们的人生。我们真的、真的很感激。我们爱你们，希望你们过个愉快的一周。是的。我们会在这里继续琢磨，
Because we like chatting.
We love to chat with you guys.
And like Colin said, we do have a fun office ladies idea that we can't wait to share about.
And now that I'm looking at these balloons, I realize I should have gotten $501 million.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
I like this.
601.
下一个我们要聊的有趣的事情会是什么。是的。因为我们喜欢聊天。我们喜欢和你们聊天。就像科林说的，我们确实有一个有趣的“办公室女士”创意，迫不及待想和大家分享。现在看着这些气球，我意识到我本该买5.01亿的。哦，是的。我不知道。我喜欢这个。6.01亿。
I'll wait for that one.
Okay, deal.
We'll see you next week.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced.
by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle
and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
我等那个。好的，一言为定。我们下周见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗。
Odyssey's executive producer
is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertry
by Creed Bratton.
You're one of those media strategy people
clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets.
Yes? Good. This is for you.
Odyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士”由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的《Ruppertry》。你是那种点击幻灯片、滚动电子表格的媒体策略人吗？是的？很好。这个是给你的。
Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different,
locked in, loyal, invested.
They're called fans.
Fans don't just listen to music.
They feel seen by it, like it belongs to them.
So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to.
And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo.
So, are you ready to talk to fans?
因为在Spotify上，有一群与众不同的受众，他们全神贯注、忠诚且投入。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不只是听音乐。他们从音乐中感受到被理解，仿佛音乐属于他们。所以当你的品牌出现在Spotify上时，这就是你在对话的对象。而且你就坐在像我这样的艺术家旁边，比如莉佐。所以，你准备好和粉丝对话了吗？
Spotify advertising.
You're among fans.
Hey, y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair.
Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if?
Like, what if it doesn't hold up?
That sofa was four days old.
You should have ordered from Wayfair.
With Wayfair, there's no what if.
Spotify广告。你在粉丝之中。嗨，大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，与Wayfair合作。你有没有在网上买过家具然后想，如果……会怎样？比如，如果它不结实怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你本该在Wayfair上买的。在Wayfair，没有“如果会怎样”。
Just style you love and quality you can trust.
Visit Wayfair.ca.
Fair, every style, every home.
只有你喜爱的风格和你可以信赖的品质。访问Wayfair.ca。Fair，每一种风格，每一个家。